bonjour à tous je suis ravie de vous
retrouver sur public sénna la polémique
enfle autour de la très contestée
réforme des collèges cette réforme qui
prévoit de revoir l'emploi du temps des
collégiens mais aussi et surtout les
programmes parmi les points de
crispation l'avenir de l'enseignement
des langues anciennes le latin et le
grec la suppression annoncée des classes
bilangues et européennes mais aussi le
programme d'histoire une semaine jour
pour jour après la publication au
Journal officiel du décret d'application
de cette réforme la commission de la
culture du Sénat auditionne ce matin les
représentants des syndicats des
enseignants et les représentants des
associations de parents d'élèves à
propos justement de cette réforme du
collège une audition qui s'annonce
plutôt à charge contre la ministre de
l'Éducation nationale Najad Belkassem
accusé par de très nombreux
parlementaires d'avoir escamoté le débat
on écoute ce qu'on disait hier soir à
notre micro la présidente centriste de
la commission de la culture Catherine
main de sali il fallait bien sûr
réfléchir à notre collège mais pas de
cette manière-là le sujet est trop
sérieux pour le prendre pour prendre
ainsi de cours voilà tout de suite
direction votre audition nous avons
organiser aujourd'hui deux tables rondes
successives euh j'ai le plaisir tout
d'abord d'accueillir les participants de
la première table ronde au nom de tous
nos collègues mesdames et messieurs
soyez les les bienvenus je rappelle que
vous
représentez les organisations suivantes
le SNES FSU le
SNF
lcfo le syndicat UNSA et puis sgenen
CFDT ainsi que les représentants du du
du SNAL et la CGT éducation je ne sais
pas si la CGT éducation est
arrivée pardonnez-moi oui excusez-moi je
suis un petit peu m alors j'ai du mal
parfois à voir les bien alors dans dans
le cadre de no mission de contrôle et et
d'information il appartient mesdames et
messieurs à notre commission de se
penger sur la réforme du collège qui est
au cœur de de l'actualité elle est mise
en œuvre comme chacun c'est par un
décret un arrêté publié la semaine
dernière au lendemain d'un mouvement de
grève les enseignants du 2 degré cette
réforme s'appuie je voulais le rappeler
sur un constat bien entendu que nous
partageons tous le collège actuel ne
parvient pas à garantir à tous
l'acquisition des savoirs fondamentaux
pas plus qui ne corrige les conséquences
liées à l'origine sociale des élèves
pourtant la réforme annoncée par la
ministre de l'Éducation nationale
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche est loin on le constate de
faire consensus ces principales
dispositions sont fortement contestées à
l' star de la réduction des 20 % des
horaires d'enseignement disciplinaire et
la fin des options de langue anciennes
au profit d'enseignement pratique
interdisciplinaire ou encore de la
suppression des classes bilangues et des
sections européennes d'autres questions
notamment celle relative à l'orientation
demeure en suspend cette réforme je
voulais aussi en préambule le rappeler
s'accompagne d'une refonde des
programmes de l'enseignement primaire
comme du collège une consultation est
engagée sur le fondement des projets de
programme élaborés par le Conseil
supérieur des programmes instan
indépendant placé auprès du ministre
dont son membres nos collègues
Marie-Christine Blandin et Jacques
Bernard manier et jusqu'il y a peu
Jacques groperin dès lors nous comptons
sur vous mesdames et messieurs pour nous
éclairer pour éclairer les réflexions et
les travaux de notre commission nous
souhaiterions connaître vos positions
sur la philosophie et les dispositions
de de cette réforme cela nous ser sera
très utile notamment en prévision de
l'audition de Madame la Ministre la
semaine prochaine donc je vous propose
de vous exprimer à tour de rôle de
manière assez synthétique 5 minutes
chacun de manière à ce qu'on puisse très
vite engager le débat avec les collèges
qui vont avoir beaucoup de questions à
vous poser en premier lieu bien entendu
je donnerai la parole à notre rapporteur
Jean-Claude Carles mais je tenais à à
souligner l'importance de ce dialogue
avec les élus voilà donc je je propose
de commencer
euh par
euh les représentants du snesfsu madame
Frédérique Rollet vous êtes csecrétaire
général je vous donne la
paroleou c'est bon voilà merci Madame
euh alors je tiens à dire en préalable
que nous pensions qu'il fallait une
réforme du du collège le gouvernement
ayant d'abord engagé une réforme de de
l'école primaire la loi de refondation
rappelant quelles étaient les
difficultés avec lesquelles 25 % des
élèves entré au collège et la nécessité
de commencer par le premier degré avant
d'aborder la question du collège ensuite
l'on sait que depuis l'instauration de
la loi habille et du collège d'
unique on s'est un peu contenté de
mettre tous les élèves dans le même lieu
en pensant qu'il suffisait de les mettre
dans le même lieu pour que tous accède à
une culture scolaire qui évidemment est
très éloignée parfois de la culture
familiale et on fait effectivement le
constat que les inégalités sociales sont
extrêmement corrélées au parcours
scolaire des des des élèves donc réforme
du collège nécessaire encore fallait-il
partir d'un bon diagnostic quels sont
les problèmes du collège des taux
d'encadrement qui se sont effondrés
entre 1999 et 2010 alors que quand on
regarde la moyenne des pays de l'OCDE
les taux avaient tendance à s'améliorer
on est passé à un nombre d'élèves par
classe plus important dans les collèges
français ensuite une difficulté à
permettre une diversification des
situations d'apprentissage le collège
disposant de très peu de moyens de faire
des groupes d'avoir une meilleure prise
en compte des élèves en difficulté sur
ces ces base la loi de refondation
prévoyait que les collèges puissent
disposer d'une marge de Man dans la
gestion de leur dotation et que des
projets puissent permettre une plus
grande transversalité qu'on puisse avoir
des expérimentation sur la base du
volontariat euh il fallait donc
évidemment réfléchir à la façon de
mettre en œuvre de façon positive ces
ces principes orors euh qu'a-t-on vu
très vite une négociation qui a été
baclée puisque auelà de la question
desécit on a nous n'avons jamais discuté
de quoi que ce soit et euh la volonté
d'imposer une forme d'autonomie 20 %
d'autonomie qui ne sont pas l'autonomie
des équipes mais qui vont amener les
établissements on le sait à la lumière
de ce qui s'est passé dans le cadre de
la réforme Châtel du lycée devoir faire
des choix qui vont mettre en concurrence
à la fois les disciplines les
enseignants qui vont faire reposer tous
les arbitrages sur le chef
d'établissement pour dégager à la fois
du temps d'accompagnement pour mettre en
place de l'interdisciplinarité pour
mettre en place des groupes on constate
même que certains dédoublements qui
étaient auparavant fléchés c'est-à-dire
obligatoire pour par exemple les
sciences et VI de la terre en 6e ou bien
la technologie et là il s'agit même pas
d'améliorer les conditions c'est c'est
indispensable on ne peut pas faire de la
technologie à 2627 on ne peut pas faire
des SVT non plus et bien ces
dédoublements ne sont plus obligatoires
donc première chose c'est 20 %
d'autonomie qui vont accentuer des
politiques d'établissement très diverses
madame la ministre parle beaucoup des
par parcours dérogatoire on sait que
c'est pas les disciplines en elles-mêmes
ni les dispositifs tels les sections
bilang qui créent des inégalités ce sont
les usages sociaux et il aurait mieux
valu réfléchir à une carte des langues
vivantes réfléchir à une carte
d'implantation des options notamment
dans dans les reps que de supprimer
purement et simplement ces ces
dispositifs et là on va recréer des
parcours puisqu'on aura des
établissements qui vont privilégier
l'implantation euh de projets qui
mettent en activité les élèves déjà les
plus à même d'entrer dans la culture
scolaire et d'autres qui vont évidemment
essayer de renforcer ce qui est soutien
ce qui est donc très vite de toute façon
des inégalités ensuite sur
l'interdisciplinarité qui peut être un
outil intéressant mais dont on sait les
travaux de un certain nombre de
chercheurs en scienceéducation le
montrre c'est quelque chose qui est
difficile à appréhender justement pour
les élèves les plus éloignés de la
culture scolaire puisque ça suppose de
faire le lien entre les notions de deux
disciplines et si on veut que ce soit
fructueux que ce soit pas quelque chose
de superficiel euh c'est c'est
chronophages ça demande la concertation
pour les enseignants ça demande de la
formation ça demande des possibilités de
cointervention et ça demande euh des
notions qui soient accrochées au
programme et je tiens à dire que le
Conseil superur des programmes euh a
fait part de son mécontentement de voir
son travail interrompu puisqu'il
réfléchissait sur justement des notions
dans identifi dans les programmes
disciplinaires alors qu'on leur a opposé
h thématiques de pays très éloigné
justement de ces de ces programmes donc
voilà encore une fois une réforme qui
s'est contenté de pronner un certain
nombre de termes interdisciplinarité
autonomie sans réfléchir aux conditions
d'application sans réfléchir à ce que
voulent les enseignants du 2 degré qui
demandent essentiellement d'abord du
temps aussi avec leurs élèves et des
dispositifs d'aide qui soi euh
opératoire donc en conclusion je dirais
que va apporter cette réforme aux élèves
en difficulté quasiment rien et elle
risque de de mettre en concurrence
encore une fois beaucoup
d'établissements beaucoup de disciplines
d'instaurer un climat dans les
établissements peu propice au travail en
en équipe et on risque donc de rater
l'occasion d'avoir une réforme du
collège qui tente de regarder comment on
prend mieux en compte les élèves les
plus en
difficulté bien je vous merci de de
votre concision je donne maintenant la
parole à Madame ophéli ogog qui
représente le syndicat national force
ouvrièr des lycée des collèges foo oui
alors c'est moi qui bonjour à tous C'est
moi qui veis intervenir en fait
euh c'est ce qu'on a décidé he donc le
syndicat effo des lycées et des collèges
demande l'abrogation de la réforme du
collège comme il a exprimé dans le
communiqué intersyndical du 21 mai avec
les autres organisations signataires
représentant 80 % des personnels aux
dernières élections professionnelles
cette réforme se présente comme un
remède à l'inégalité et au niveau
insuffisant des élèves dans les savoirs
fondamentaux comme vous l'avez rappelé
notamment en math et en français peut-on
croire que l'autonomie des
établissements c'est-à-dire 20 % de la
DAG qui serait défin donc de la dotation
globale qui serait définie localement
peuton croire que cette autonomie serait
compatible avec l'égalité l'autonomie
des établissements reviendrait en fait à
la situation suivante he 5000 collèges
donc 5000 contenus différents pour les
20 % de de ces de laadag donc cela
entraînerait comme l'a dit d'ailleurs
Frédéric rol une concurrence entre les
établissements et une inégalité entre
les élèves au
contraire par ailleurs les enseignements
pratiques
interdisciplinaire seraitorganisé sur
une partie des horaires disciplinaires
il s'agit de ponctionner des horaires
dis moi de
français pouvez-vous mettre votre micro
s'il vous plaît en appuyant sur le
bouton dédié merci comment je il faut
appuyer en fait en même temps ah
d'accord ah d'accord
C il Mar
plus ok
excusez-moi donc comme je disais les
igns prqu disciplinaire pourquoi pas
mais ça reviendrait à enfin dans le
cadre de la réforme ces enseignements
interdisciplinaires seraient organisés
sur des horaires disciplinaires donc
moins d'orthographe moins de gramire
pour les élèves ce qui ne correspond pas
à ce qu'on attend et au problème qui a
été pointé par ailleurs ponctionner
ponctionner les horaires disciplinaires
reviendrait ici on a fait le calcul de
la 6e à la 3e à 400 heur de cours en
moins consacré justement aux disciplines
à partentière soit la moitié d'une année
de de cours
par ailleurs les programmes ser seraiit
organisé par cycle de 3 ans et non de
manière annuelle voilà donc ça pose un
problème aussi du point de vue de la
progressivité de l'apprentissage et de
l'évaluation des élèves puisque de fait
un élève qui n'aurait pas acquis au bout
d'un an
euh comment dire les savoirs nécessaires
euh redoublerait dans enfin redouble
dans le cadre actuel là il faudrait
attendre 3
ans la question des dédoublements SVT en
technologie ça me semble évident aussi
qu'en technologie quand il s'agit de
manipuler des comment dire des outils
parfois dangereux il est préférable
quand même de travailler en demi-groupe
plutôt que à
27 par ailleurs en classe de 6e on on a
actuellement des 6e à 30 dans les
établissements à 30 élèves par classe il
faut le savoir quand même
donc dernière chose peut-on réellement
penser qu'en supprimant le latin en tant
que discipline à part entière en SUP
supprimant les classes bilanges on
améliorera le niveau des élèves nous ne
le pensons pas par ailleurs on ne peut
pas dire que ce soit seulement les
élèves des comment dire qui
appartiennent à un milieu privilégié qui
participe à ces cours là puisqu'il
existe des cours de latin et des classes
bilang dans les
établissements de zone d'éducation
prioritaire par ailleurs la suppression
des classes bilang menace actuellement
1200 poste donc cette réforme en fait
apparaît plus comme un moyen finalement
de faire des économies hein apprendre
moins et dépenser moins c'est un peu
comme ça que nous le voyons donc ce qui
serait nécessaire à l'amélioration de
l'apprentissage ce que nous demandons
c'est un allègement des effectifs par
classe alors que depuis des années les
effectifs par classe ne cessent
d'augmenter à la rentrée on prévoit
encore une augmentation des effectifs
par
classe et donc après la la désastreus
réforme des rythmes scolaires toujours
contesté la réforme du collège s'inscrit
dans le cadre de la loi de refondation
de l'école et de la réforme territoriale
et c'est encore une des facettes du
pacte de responsabilité et des 54
milliards de coupes dans les dépenses
publiques donc nous ne voulons pas de
cette réforme les collègues n'en veulent
pas ils étaient majoritairement en grève
le 19 mai je pense que je pense qu'on
peut le rappeler et dès lors la
publication du décret et de l'arrêté
d'application le lendemain de la grève a
suscité chez chez les collègues une
indignation une indignation assez forte
il continue à à s'opposer donc à cette
réforme et à demander l'abrogation voilà
je remercie infiniment Monsieur Frédéric
sè pour le Syndicat général de
l'Éducation nationale je vous donne la
parole et je vous en remercie alors pour
être
synthétique plusieurs éléments tout le
monde s'accorde effectivement qu'il y
avait une urgence et une absolue
nécessité à réformer le
collège le collège queun ministre
antérieur avait qualifié très justement
de Maillan souffrant du système éducatif
souffrance pour les élèves effectivement
puce que c'est au collège que se
concrétise un décrochage et des
difficultés scolaires qui se creusent
certes avant mais c'est bien au collège
que ça apparaît souffrance également
pour les personnels on l'oublie toujours
la société s'est accommodé pendant de
nombreuses années des dysfonctionnements
du collège mais elle en laissait la
gestion et le coût au collègues chargés
de faire tourner malgré tout les
établissements urgence également à cause
des stratégies de personnel
effectivement c encore une fois cet
abandon ou ce relative cette relative
négligence de la société face à l'échec
du collège générait et c'est bien
compréhensible des stratégies familiales
de contournement d'évitement ce que la
société ce que l'État ne ne se donnait
plus comme mission de garantir
absolument et bien ma fois la réussite
les familles allaient la chercher par
elle-même hein donc on avait une une une
situation où l'école publique où la
l'école pour tous le collège unique hein
qui date de 75 se détricotait
progressivement et j'allais dire presque
irrémédiablement il y avait également il
y avait une urgence il y avait également
une opportunité parce que parce que
cette réforme du collège s'accompagne
d'une réforme des programmes
ça'accompagne également d'une réforme de
l'évaluation donc d'une réforme du socle
commun donc tout un ensemble de réformes
qui peuvent donner une sens qui peuvent
donner un sens hein qui peuvent donner
une cohérence globale et donc qui sont
non pas une certitude mais enfin engage
un élément efficacité globale le fait
que l'on réforme globalement la
scolarité obligatoire donne une chance
encore une fois supplémentaire de
réussir une réforme de cette ampleur là
et de cette nécessité
là le sens de cette réforme également
enfin le sens de la réforme qu'il
fallait qu'il faut tout le monde
s'accorde aussi dessus sur le sens à
donner même si on s'accorde pas tous sur
les moyens à mettre en œuvre réduction
des inégalités je ne pourrait faire se
faire écho de T tous les rapports por
mais même non seulement français mais
même mondiaux he qui soulligne
l'explosion des inégalités ces dernières
années et qui soulligne aussi le rôle
qu'on joué que jouent les inégalités
scolaires dans la dynamique des des
inégalités globales économiques et
sociales donc il fallait effectivement
prendre la question à bras le corp se
donner comme impératif comme objectif de
réduire les inégalités c'est-à-dire de
faire réussir tous les élèves de faire
réussir tous les élèves pour retrouver
encore une fois une école obligatoire
une
école école primaire collège qui soit
bien destiné à tout le monde qui soit
destiné à la réussite de tous et qui
donc parce qu'elle tient cette promesse
là rend moins nécessaire et donc sans
doute moins rendra sans doute moins
fréquente les stratégies individualistes
de contournement encore une fois qui
fleurissent actuellement alors sur le
fond de la réforme une fois que les
objectifs sont calés comment s'y
prend-on comment fallait-il s'y prendre
le S CDTA a peser pour que on cesse
d'avoir des réformes jctive qui
prescrivent des contenus qui explique
aux collègues ce qu'il faut faire
exactement comment à quelle heure et
dans quel sens mais qui s'inspire au
contraire de ce que les collègues ont
fait pendant que la société le l'État a
détourné un peu les yeux du
collège des collègues localement
justement pour faire tenir leurs
collègues leurs collèges pardon mais
leurs collègues aussi d'ailleurs hein
pour garder essayer de conserver le sens
et le le sens de leur mission ont innové
inventé pris des initiatives d'ailleurs
on n' pas besoin de mot trè ronflan pour
désigner ce qu'ils ont fait ont inventé
des choses des dispositifs ben il
fallait d'une part s'inspirer de ces
innovations du terrain et surtout en
tirer la conclusion que ceux qui sont le
plus à même de choisir de déterminer de
mettre en œuvre ce qui est bon pour les
élèves ce sont d'abord les collègues au
contact justement de ces élèves au
contact de la réalité des populations
des familles et des territoires donc
nous avons posé pour que cette réforme
ne soit pas injonctive mais au contraire
accorde le maximum de liberté
pédagogique nouvelle aux équipes
éducatives pour leur permettre encore
une fois de remplir leur mission de
s'adapter à leur public de prendre en
compte les difficultés particulières de
leur public parce que si les élèves ont
tous le même si on donne à tous à tous
les élèves le même objectif si on s ils
ont tous le même
droit à un avenir ils ne sont pas ils ne
partent pas tous du même point ils n'ont
pas tous exactement les mêmes
difficultés et c'est bien aux collègues
de s'adapter enfin de prendre en charge
cette diversité il fallait donc leur
donner les moyens de le faire c'est pour
ça que pour nous la clé de cette réforme
au-delà de tout ce qu'on peut dire sur
les langues les langues et cultures de
l'antiquité ou certains dispositifs
dérogatoires le fond du fond l'essentiel
c'est la marge d'autonomie accordée aux
équipes éducatives nous aurions nous
d'ailleurs souhaité qu'elle soit plus
importante encore marge d'initiative
dans la détermination du contenu des
enseignements mais dans l'organisation
auss de ces enseignements organisation
dans l'année organisation sur le
cycle alors cette réforme a je dirais
pris cette direction même si elle n'est
pas allée aussi loin in que nousons
souhaité elle va dans le bon sens de ce
point de vue-là maintenant une réforme
vous l'avez rappelé madame c'est pour
l'instant c'est la réforme c'est un
arrêté un décret hein et de j'allais
dire deux textes réglementaires ne
constituent pas une réforme l'essentiel
de la réforme ça se fera sur le terrain
justement la réforme une politique
éducative c'est d'avoord le travail des
personnels donc la réforme je dirais
elle est encore devant nous he on en a
le cadre réglementaire il faut encore la
concrétiser en travail en politique
éducative et pour ça il y a encore
beaucoup à faire tout d'abord puisque
l'on passe à un modèle de encore une
fois de pilotage alors passe la
révolution culturelle n'est pas complète
n'est pas complètement achevé mais tout
de même on glisse on va dire comme ça
d'un modèle injonctif à un modèle où les
établissements sont plus autonomes il va
falloir globalement donner les moyens de
autonomie parce que l'autonomie ça se
gère localement ça demande des moyens ça
demande des dispositions des
organisations différentes alors on peut
différen comment dirais-je différencier
ou distinguer de de temps il y a d'abord
la préparation de la rentrée 2016
puisque là il s'agit de se d'inventer en
quelque sorte he des choses des façons
de faire des dispositifs qui n'avait pas
cours jusqu'à maintenant dont les
équipes n'avaient pas toujours
l'habitude jusqu'à maintenant donc il
faut donner du temps au cours de l'année
2015-21 2016 aux équipe pour préparer la
rentrée 2016 il y a plusieurs modalités
on y reviendra en détail si vous le
voulez nous avons des propositions mais
garde au moins à l'esprit cette idée
qu'il faut il va falloir du temps pour
préparer cette rentrée particulière qui
sera de ce point de vue-là une entré à
nul autre pareil deuxièmement toujours
pour préparer cette rentrée il faut des
ressources des ressources je dirais en
ingénierie en compréhension il faut
mobiliser des ressources de formation
des ressources d'encadrement pour aider
les équipes à faire leur choix j'insiste
bien il s'agit pas d'aller excusez-moi
le la référence peut-être un pe
religieuse c'est pas d'ailleurs dire la
messe aux équipes pour la expliquer
comment faire mais bien de d'être à leur
côté pour les épauler pour choisir ce
qu'elles veulent faire enfin deuxème
train de j'ai de mesures hein il faut
prendre la dimension encore une fois de
cette autonomie qu'on a accordé aux
établissements pour opérer des
changements de plus long terme alors
j'en distingue deux ou deux grandes
catégories d'abord il y a le
fonctionnement des instances de
l'établissement conseil d'administration
conseil pédagogique euh dont nous ne
récusons à la différence de certains
nous ne récusons pas l'existence bien au
contraire mais ces instances ont été
imaginé formaté pour un pilotage
relativement descendant elles doivent
être adaptées à un pilotage beaucoup
plus autonome et qui donne effectivement
qui garantissent la collégialité des
décisions la transparence des décisions
deuxième élément cette autonomie des
établissements va générer ce qu'on
appelle maintenant dans notre jargon
éducation nationale à la suite du décret
du 20 août 2014 des missions
particulières il va falloir que certains
collègues s'investissent plus
particulièrement comme c'est déjà le cas
sur beaucoup d'autres sujets mais là
peut-être plus particulièrement dans le
la préparation hein le pilotage
l'encadrement de cette autonomie et ben
cet engagement particulier va il faut le
reconnaître être à terme il va falloir
donc il mette les moyens concrètement
mettre des moyens pour augmenter les
budgets d'indemnité pour mission
particulièr qui peuvent je le rappel
être versé sous forme numéraire ou sous
forme de déchargge même si le
législateur enfin le ministère a prévu
que cette dernière modalité soit
exceptionnel voilà le cadre encore une
fois les les l'origine pour nous de la
réforme la les nécessités de son contenu
et les exigen pour sa réussite je vous
remercie merci monsieur je donne
immédiatement la parole à votre
voisine de droite madame Claire creber
pour le syndicat enseignant UNSA s'il
vous plaît vous avez la
parole oui bonjour et merci de nous
avoir invité à nous exprimer sur cette
réforme du
collège pour commencer je voudrais dire
que malgré l'engagement des personnels
sur le terrain et l'engagement
quotidien le
collège n'est ni juste ni efficace
et c'est une source de souffrance
professionnelle pour les personnels bien
sûr une source de souffrance pour tous
les élèves qui sont en échec dans notre
collège je ne vais pas rappeler ce que
vous avez déjà signalé madame les échecs
l'échec massif qui marque les le collège
et le creusement des
écarts entre les plus faibles et les
meilleurs qui a lieu dans les 4 années
du collège je voudrais juste rappeler
tout de même
un point important il me semble c'est
que nos élèves les plus faibles sont
largement en dessous des élèves les plus
faibles si on considère la moyenne de
l'OCDE c'est-à-dire que nos élèves les
plus faibles ont encore moins d'acquis
que les élèves les plus faibles dans les
autres pays c'est ainsi qu'on peut dire
que notre système éducatif pour les
élèves les plus faibles est moins
efficace que le système éducatif du
Mexique par exemple ce qui est quand
même assez tragique quand on y pense
les
euh études
internationales montrent que les pays
qui ont progressé de manière
significative l'ont fait en s'attachant
à faire progresser les plus
faibles et du même coup en faisant
progresser les plus faibles ils ont ils
sont parvenus à faire progresser
l'ensemble de leurs élèves je crois
qu'il faut bien qu'on garde ça en tête
il ne s'agit pas d'opposer la réussite
des plus faibles et la réussite des
meilleurs il ne s'agit pas de parler
comme on l'entend régulièrement dans les
médias de nivellement par le bas au
contraire plus nous nous attacherons à
la réussite de nos plus faibles plus
nous porterons encore plus loin nos
meilleurs élèves pour l'instant notre
système éducatif et notre collège est
marqué par une discrimination en faveur
des
meilleurs c'est-à-dire que ce sont
toujours les meilleurs élèves qui ont
droit à plus d'heures de classe et à des
dispositifs
particulier au service de l'acquisition
de leurs
compétences il faut
donc restructurer notre collège pour se
donner effectivement les moyens de faire
réussir tous les élèves alors le
dialogue social a eu lieu il a même été
long il a d'abord été il a d'abord eu
lieu dans le cadre de de la
l'élaboration de la loi de refondation
ensuite nous avons été réunis pendant
pratiquement une année quatre ou cinq
réunions au moins pour travailler
ensemble à l'évolution du collège nous
avons ensuite participer à des
discussions pendant plusieurs mois et
enfin sur un mois des négociations ont
eu lieu autour de la grille
horaire ce qui nous paraît nous
essentiel au sunsa dans cette réforme ce
dont on parle peu d'ailleurs hein ce
sont les marges ce qu'on appelle
techniquement les marges he
prof qui sont multiplié par 8 dans le
cadre de cette réforme pardon par 6 dans
le cadre de cette réforme et qui sont
donc la clé de la réduction de la
discrimination quand on prend un collège
moyen c'est-à-dire un collège de 16
classes on va bénéficier au lieu des 8h
actuellement proposé dans les grilles
horaires pour faire des groupes à
effectif réduits on va bénéficier de 40
Twitter ce qui est considérable ce qui
veut dire que nous allons pouvoir enfin
ce que demandent tous les enseignants
nous allons pouvoir enfin mettre en
place des groupes à effectif réduits
pour mieux nous attacher à la réussite
de tous les élèves nous allons pouvoir
aussi proposer de la coanimation de
manière à travailler à deux enseignants
avec les mêmes élèves et à donner du
sens aux apprentissages et à mieux
observer nos élèves en train d'apprendre
pour mieux résoudre leurs difficultés
avec eux cette réforme elle s'appuie
largement sur les pratiques enseignantes
mon collègue l'a déjà dit et elle n'est
pas une révolution mais plutôt une
évolution elle est modeste dans le sens
où elle s'ajuste aux
possibilités et à l'avancée de la
réflexion dans les
équipes on a beaucoup glosé sur sur les
epepi on allait voler des heures au
disciplines on va voler des heures au
disciplines premier appel les EP ça
représente en tout et pour tout de 6 à
9h sur les 104 heures de classe que
reçoit un élève de collège donc vous
voyez qu'on est loin de mettre en péril
les enseignements disciplinaires on les
met d'autant moins en péril que ces EP
sont bien sûr inscrits dans les contenu
des
programmes et donc qu'on y fera ce qu'on
y fait de toute façon dans les
enseignements bien entendu mais
simplement avec des modalités
pédagogiques
diversifiées l'accompagnement
personnalisé à noté 3h en 6e pour aider
nos élèves à entrer dans les exigences
du collège
3h l'accompagnement personnalisé n'est
pas une
nouveauté il me semble qu'une majorité
différente quand elle était aux affaires
l'a institué au collège pardon au lycée
on est donc bien dans une forme de
continuité on peut même dire que les EPI
marquent une certaine continuité avec
des choix qui ont été faits dans la
réforme du lycée sous la forme des
enseignements d'exploration donner du
sens aux apprentissages permettre aux
élèves d'être plus
actifs travailler en groupe voilà euh
des euh démarches qui existent dans
d'autres niveaux et qui qui ont montré
leur
pertinence cette réforme elle est fondée
sur
l'autonomie l'autonomie ça n'est pas la
liberté ça n'est pas le grand n'importe
quoi c'est la
responsabilité et c'est la confiance
c'est la confiance qu'on fait aux
équipes pour pouvoir construire
localement les réponses aux besoins
locaux c'est aussi
redonner du pouvoir d'agir aux
enseignants leur redonner la fierté de
leur métier leur redonner la possibilité
de j'allais d'utiliser un terme un peu
un peu familier de s'éclater de
s'éclater pédagogiquement avec leurs
élèves parce qu'ils vont pouvoir les
faire mieux réussir alors la réussite de
la réforme bien sûr elle elle n'est pas
que dans les textes même si les textes
sont importants
elle est surtout dans l'accompagnement
de sa mise en œuvre et cet
accompagnement il passe par la formation
initiale et la formation continue dont
je rappellerai comment elles ont été
mises à mal toutes les deux par la
majorité précédente il y a donc un
effort essentiel à mener sur cette
formation initiale et cette formation
continue sans oublier pour autant qu'on
a une autre priorité essentielle c'est
celle de faire réussir nos élèves à
l'école
primaire notre chance c'est que cette
réforme
elle est systémique elle passe à la fois
par la réform de la formation par la
réforme des programmes par la réforme de
l'évaluation et peut-être nous
l'espérons par la réforme du
DNB il y a urgence il y a urgence pour
notre collège il y a urgence pour notre
système éducatif public il est temps il
nous semble de sortir des polémiques
sans fondement des polémiques stériles
pour porter tous ensemble ce nouveau
collège nous en partageons tous les
principes nous en partageons tous les
principes
il est très important que nous
réussissions cette réforme si nous
voulons garantir le vivre ensemble dans
notre dans notre République si vous si
nous voulons garantir également la
réussite économique de notre
pays je rappellerai également que pour y
parvenir à ces deux sur ces deux points
le vivre ensemble et la réussite
économique il y a des enjeux qui ne sont
pas uniquement des enjeux du système
éducatif il faut aussi que nos Collectiv
prennent leur responsabilité avec les
services de l'État pour développer la
mixité scolaire et sociale dans tous les
établissements et c'est aussi un très
très fort enjeu qu'il nous faut porter
parce que la différence entre les
collèges c'est aussi cela l'absence de
mixité scolaire et social merci madame
je donne la parole au représentant du du
SNAL Monsieur François portser son
président merci madame la Présidente
messieurs mesames les les les
sénateurs je vous remercie de nous
auditionner aujourd'hui alors la
première chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que euh nous sommes également
conscients et nous avons été les
premiers à le dénoncer des des
manquements que connaît à l'heure
actuelle le collège marqué notamment par
le fait qu'un/art des élèves sont en
situation d'échec donc ce que je
voudrais d'abord souligner c'est que
notre organisation ne se résout pas à
l'immobilisme il ne s'agit pas de d'être
contre cette réforme pendant rien faire
nous avons d'ailleurs il y a déjà 2 ans
proposé un projet alternatif pour le
collège qui s'appelle le collège
modulaire qui est expérimenté en
particulier dans un collège de la band
d'angoulê le collège Élisabeth
badinterre à la couronne et qui est
fondé sur le fait que en 5e en 4e en 3e
en math en français et en anglais on les
élèves qui ont le plus de difficulté
soit pris en charge en petit groupe sans
qu'il y ait une quelconque sérégation
donc nous nous partage un diagnostique
sur la nécessité de faire cette réforme
mais cette réforme pour nous n'est pas
la bonne et nous en demandons
l'abrogation et l'ouverture de N de
nouvell véritable nouvelles négociations
avant de rentrer effectivement dans dans
le vif du
sujet il faut bien avoir conscience que
cette réforme a été imposée de manière
tout à fait enfin rapide sans
véritablement de concertation nous avons
eu en quelques semaines trois réunions
au cours de la dernière d'ailleurs nous
sommes sortis puisque nous voyons qu'il
n'y avait pas moyen
d'avancer ces ces réunions on on a eu un
projet qui était déjà ficelé on nous
demandait quasiment de changer les
virgules mais il y avait aucune
possibilité d'avoir une réflexion de
fond et vous l'avez vu dans l'actualité
récente la manière dont être fait le
dialogue social dans l'éducation
nationale qui consiste à faire passer un
décret pour faire appliquer cette
réforme alors même que la manifestation
est à peine finie le jour de donc le
jour de la grève du 19 mai dernier et
c'est véritablement un camoufl un dénis
de démocratie donc c'est pas comme ça
que une réforme qui va impacter la vie
de milliers d'élèves pour des années à
venir doiv être pris en compte il faut
écouter le l'opinion de d'organisation
syndical qui représente la large
majorité des enseignants du secondaire
pour que que la réforme du collège
puisse se faire alors maintenant sur la
réforme elle-même qu'est-ce que nous
reprochons à cette réforme premier
problème on diminue les horaires
disciplinaires on a vu récemment les
difficultés que les collégiant Français
ont en math mais cette réforme euh
ampute les horaires disciplinaires ce
n'est pas sérieux les enfants ont besoin
davantage de de d'horaires
disciplinaires pour reminer leur
difficulté pas d'une diminution on nous
vend encore une fois
l'interdisciplinaire par le biais des
épis l'interdisciplinaire serait la
solution miracle pour remédier aux
difficultés c'est faux il y a eu par le
passé par exemple les IDD qui ont on été
un fiasco total donc dire que
l'interdisciplinaire est une solution au
problème et faux nous ne sommes pas
opposés à ce processus s'il repose sur
le volontariat et s'il n'empute pas
encore une fois les erreurs
disciplinaires parce que les les épis se
font sur le dos des erreurs
disciplinaire et encore une fois leur
efficacité tout à fait douteuse autre
problème la confusion que cette réforme
introduit dans dans l'enseignement des
disciplines artistiques on ne sait plus
trop comment les choses vont se faire
les difficultés également dans les
disciplines scientifique on mélange la
physique les SVT la technologie en
amputant des moyens une collègue la cité
on ne peut pas sérieusement travailler
avec des horaires moins importants et et
plus de dédoublement dans une discipline
comme la technologie on supprime un
véritable l'enseignement du latin et du
grec il s'agit pas de passer des des
vidéos sur la guerre de TR il s'agit
d'avoir un véritable enseignement de
qualitéin où on apprenne
véritablement la vertu formatrice du
latin et du grec et dans le dispositif
qui est qui est qui est mis en place ce
n'est plus le cas et j'insiste aussi sur
le fait qu'il faut arrêter de nous faire
croire que l'enseignement du latin du
grec c'est quelque chose d'élitiste je
vous rappelle qu'en sensi par exemple il
y a des parents sont très content il y a
de plus en plus de demandes pour faire
du latin et du grec donc il faut
augmenter à l'URE actuelle 20 % des
élèves qu'il font il s'agit pas de
diminuer il s'agit de l'augmenter et
d'arrêter de taxer d'élitisme une
formation véritablement indispens sable
à dépissant de beaucoup d'enfants
ensuite on supprime des dispositifs qui
fonctionnent on supprime les classes
européennes on supprime les classes
bilangues sans même parler également de
l'enseignement des langues régionales
auquell nous sommes très attachés donc
c'est C suppression ce fonctionnement de
toutes ces disciplines enfin toutes ces
dispositifs qui fonctionnent sont certes
à l'heure
actuelle choisi par une minorité
d'élèves mais pourquoi parce qu'on donne
pas les moyens pour qu'il y en a est
plus nous sommes pour le fait qu'il y a
un maximum d'élèves qui fassent qui
participent à ces dispositifs donc on
est en train de casser quelque chose qui
marche avec j'y reviendrai tout à
l'heure le risque de mécontenter les
familles et de d'entraîner déperdition
de l'enseignement public vers
l'enseignement privé on nous parle
également de de l'autonomie comme
solution à tous les problèmes pour nous
l'autonomie qui nous est proposée c'est
pas l'autonomie des établissements c'est
l'autonomie des chefs d'établissement
avec un risque d'inégalité croissant
entre les établissements que que nous
contestons tout à fait au final
véritablement le le nœud du problème je
l'ai évoqué tout à l'heure alors que le
le vrai problème c'est le fait qu'il a
25 % des élèves qui sont en difficulté
rien n'est fait concrètement pour que
ces élèves puissent remédier à leur
difficultés et acquérir un savoir
fondamental qui leur permettra de
réussir parce que rien n'est fait pour
prendre en petit groupe les élèves en
difficulté au cours leité au
collège alors au final ça pour nous
effectivement ce cette réforme du
collège est grave parce que derrière il
y aura on l'a dit une réforme de
l'évaluation une réforme des programmes
des programmes je rappelle qu'en
français à l'heure actuelle le mot
grammaire ou m complément d'objet direct
n'est pas prévu dans les programmes de
français donc on va rêver euh et à
l'heure actuelle derrière une réforme du
lycée on a vu déjà les les effets
catastrophiques de la réforme précédente
au lycée on en prépare une qui va qui
risque d' pire et tout ça va pour nous
dans le mauvais sens nous nous sommes
depuis 1905 un syndicat qui défend
l'école de la République c'est un
enseignement de qualité pour tous et
nous récusons le modèle universel actuel
qui est un modèle qui veut que l'école
publque soit une école pour les pauvres
une école de mauvaise qualité et que
l'enseignement de qualité comme c'est
malheureusement le cas dans la plupart
des pays du monde soit réservé une élite
sociale de l'argent nous notre combat
c'est un enseignement de qualité pour
tous quel que soit son son origine et
avec cette réforme contrairement à ce
que dit la ministre à grand renfort de
coup médiatique tout AB mute on ne va
pas dans le sens de davantage d'égalité
pour les élèves on va vers une
détérioration de cette égalité et la fin
de l'école publique donc nous au SNAL
nous sommes là 05 et on ne laissera pas
cette gabgie se
poursuivre merci monsieur je donne la
parole à notre dernier
invité orateur pour ce premier tour de
piste monsieur mich lou pour la CGT
éducation je vous remerci euh nous
sommes d'accord et je pense que c'était
assez partagé ici pour dire que le
collège ne remplissait pas toujours pas
sa mission et que il était le grand
oublié des réformes de ces dernières
années et même on peut le dire depuis la
création du collège unique que nous
soutenons toujours évidemment il a été
on n pas réussi à à faire passer une
phase de démocratisation après la phase
de massification donc il était
intéressant de pouvoir discuter d'une
réformme forme simplement comme ça a été
dit effectivement en terme de discussion
ça a été relativement court puisque nous
n'avons eu au niveau syndical que trois
réunions devant un projet quasiment
ficelé et sans possibilité
d'intervention et malgré nos demandes
réitérées de demander un peu de temps
pour se concerter et pour améliorer ce
qui pouvait l'être dans cette réforme
nous ce qui nous pose le plus le
principal problème c'est l'autonomie des
établissements parce que comme ça a été
dit on essaie de nous dire que c'est
l'autonomie des équipes pédagogiques
mais ce n'est absolument pas le cas on a
vu déjà dans la réforme châtelle des
lycées cette autonomie c'est bel et bien
celle du chef d'établissement qui décide
de la répartition des moyens dont il a à
disposition en terme de de dédoublement
par exemple et de travail à effectif
réduit non pas suivant l'intérêt des
élèves non pas suivant l'idée d'un
cadrage national de ce qui devrait être
l'intérêt des élèves comme par exemple
se dire que nationalement on peut
supposer penser que il faut de
travailler en effectif réduit
prioritairement en langue
prioritairement en science si on le
pense tous et bien écrivonsle dans les
les cadres règlementaires donc c'est
bien cette autonomie là qui n'est pas
celle du tout des des équipes mais bien
du C d'établissement qui peut décider
des dédoublements souvent et très
souvent en fonction de la dotation
académique de personnel effectivement
quand on est dans des disciplines comme
les mathématiques où on manque de
personnel et bien ce sont les
mathématiques qu'on dédoublera le moins
pour pour prendre un exemple ça c'est de
la gestion c'est l'autonomie de gestion
certainement pas de l'autonomie
pédagogique nous ce que nous réclamons
si vraiment on veut de l'autonomie
pédagogique c'est partir des projets des
collègues comme parce que les collègues
heureusement de l'interdisciplinaire ils
en font déjà ils font des projets
simplement là ce n'est pas en en leur
demandant d'aller chercher à tout prix à
faire des projets en qui alors qu'ils
éent à tort ou à raison en leur faisant
penser que c'est au détriment de leur
discipline qu'on arrivera à faire un
vrai travail de projet
interdisciplinaire c'est au contraire en
donnant une marge supplémentaire de
moyens dans les établissements pour
permettre ces projets et et et ces
moyens ça ça veut dire notamment de la
concertation parce que c'est intéressant
dans cette réforme de dire que les EP
nous à la cgité éducaction n'est pas
forcément opposé à l'interdisciplinarité
on pense même que si c'est bien fait ça
peut être intéressant sous une certaine
dose simplement faire de
l'interdisciplinarité sans donner les
moyens fléchés pour faire la
cointervention entre collègues de
plusieurs disciplines ce n'est pas de
l'interdisciplinarité faire de
l'interdisciplinarité sans sans donner
de la concertation pour la préparer ce
n'est pas faire de la bonne
interdisciplinarité et cette réforme là
elle sera un échec pour cette raison-là
sur le donc pour nous le principal
problème de cette réforme c'est
l'autonomie c'est la mise en concurrence
des établissements avec des epis où on
en fera 6 sur 8 donc ça veut dire que
quand même dans les établissements on ne
fera pas tous tous les élèves ne feront
pas la même chose entre deux
établissements c'est la mise en
concurrence des disciplines c'est en
plus faire peser la gestion de la
pénurie en heure de au collège au
personnel c'est essayer de leur faire
croire que si ils ont ils sont en échec
c'est de leur faute puisqu'ils avaient
les moyens de d'ajuster à la marge les
quelques heures qu'on leur laissait en
plus donc pour nous cette réforme elle
est à rejeter pour cette raison là parce
qu'elle ne part pas du travail et de du
dévouement des collègues dans les
collèges compris les collèges les plus
difficiles les solutions alors il y a
pas de solution malheureusement ou
heureusement peut-être d'ailleurs clé en
main simplement déjà il faudra réfléchir
quand même au fait que les effectifs par
classe depuis des années maintenant
après la suppression de 80000 postes
notamment ces dernières années les
effectifs par classe sont toujours aussi
élevés en collège on peut très bien
réussir à travailler
euh autrement mais simplement travailler
autrement avec des effectifs aussi
lourds c'est extrêmement compliqué et à
aucun moment n'est abordé cette cette
question là les même oublié comme elle
l'a été dans la réforme de l'éducation
prioritaire où aucun moyen n'a été donné
pour alléger les classes le travail en
groupe c'est une idée c'est très bien
mais à condition de le flécher
nationalement en tout cas en partie
qu'il y ait une
partie qu'on puisse qui puisse être
utilisé au sein des équipes pour
quelques dédoublements spécifiques
pourquoi pas simplement encore une fois
on peut estimer que nationalement il est
crédible de dire que certaines
disciplines doivent être prioritairement
euh travailler en effectif réduit et
mettre un cadre national pour cela donc
le parce qu'on effectivement il y a des
travaill les heures effectif réduit ont
ét augmentés on on ne le niit pas
simplement dans le même temps on a on
introduit l'accompagnement personnalisé
à 30 enfin à 28 ça dépend des classes ou
à 26 et si on veut faire de
l'accompagnement personnalisé parce que
personnalisé ça veut pas dire
individualisé ça veut dire que en fait
vous avez 26 élèves devant vous et en
théorie vous leur donnez 26 choses
différentes à faire je caricature un peu
volontiers je l'avoue volontier
simplement quand on crée
l'accompagnement personnalisé sans lui
donner forcément des moyens fléchés pour
le
dédoubler quand on crée les EPI sans
donner des moyens pour soit soit
travailler effectif réduit soit
permettre la cointervention des
collègues ça veut dire qu'on laisse les
collègues décider entre des
dédoublements en science des
dédoublements en langue ou dédoubler la
paix ou dédoubler les épis donc encore
une fois on fait porter la gestion de la
Perie sur sur les collègues le donc de
l'interdisciplinarité travailler
autrement oui pas n'importe comment et
ça ça veut dire des moyens des moyens de
conculttation de formation des collègues
parce qu'on nous promet suite à la à
l'apparition du décret que le 2016 enfin
2015 2016 sera l'année de la formation
moi je suis enseignant depuis 12 ans ça
fait 12 ans que j'entends que on va
vooir enfin un vrai plan de formation
dans l'éducation nationale et depuis 12
ans j'attends
toujours
je je vous remercie de cette
présentation je vais donner
immédiatement la la parole à notre
rapporteur pour les crédits de
l'éducation nationale Jean-Claude Carles
puis à Madame ferra qui je tenais le
préciser rapporteur des crédits
spécifique pour l'enseignement agricole
j'ai déjà noté des demandes de prise de
parole mes chers collègues je vous
demande tous parce que c'est un sujet
auquel nous sommes attachés nous allons
être nombreux à vouloir poser des
questions à être relativement
synthétique les uns et les autres pour
chacun puisse s'exprimer monsieur Carles
vous avez la parole merci madame la
Présidente je voudrais remercier donc
les intervenants de être venu devant
nous pour nous donner leur position sur
cette réforme du du collège la plupart
d'entre vous juge jugez nécessaire cette
réforme mais elle fait naître un certain
nombre
d'inquiétude de crainte et de positionos
assez marqué puisque certains d'entre
vous en de même en demande même euh
l'abrogation je voudrais revenir sur ce
qu'a dit la représentante de l'UNSA qui
a dit que le collège n'est ni juste ni
efficace et effectivement he les
statistiques sont là pour le montrer
puisque 20 % des jeunes qui entrent au
collège ne maîtrisent pas les
fondamentaux et c'est à peu près la même
proportion à la sortie du collège donc
on le voit bien le collège n'arrive pas
à résorber les inégalités d'entrée et
justement est-ce que l'effort ne devrait
pas être porté dès le début et sur
l'enseignement primaire le cycle du
primaire car chacun le sait le l'avenir
scolaire d'un jeune est quasiment Cellé
quand il termine le cycle du primaire et
que ne faudrait-il pas mettre l'accent
sur la maîtrise des fondamentaux dès
l'entrée au collège car comme le disait
pegy lire écrire compter c'est euh la
base de tout et que je crains que sans
ça allit euh euh les les efforts qui
sont faits pour la réforme du collège ne
soi pas efficace et j'en viens au
euh la mise en place des enseignements
inter disciplinaires qui vont se faire
sur au détriment des enseignements
disciplinaires et en particulier sur le
français qui est en constante diminution
depuis de nombreuses années est-ce qu'il
ne faudrait pas là aussi REM mettre
l'effort sur cette discipline et quant à
la pertinence même des enseignements
interdisciplinaires c'est vrai qu'on
peut s'interroger ça a été évoqué par
l'un d'entre vous notamment lorsque on
se rappelle la mise en place des
itinéraires de découvert tout dans un
autre segment des TPE dans les lycées on
a vu que cert il y avait un intérêt mais
que les résultats n'étaient pas à la
hauteur de ce qu'on pouvit espérer
est-ce que ça ne va pas là aussi
aggraver les inégalités et bénéficier
aux élèves les meilleurs plutôt qu'à
ceux qui sont en difficulté puis une
autre question si vous le permettez sur
qui touche l'orientation et notamment la
suppression des tions de
découverte professionnelle et là encore
est-ce qu'on va encore pas euh aggraver
la situation de la voie professionnelle
et écarter encore davantage les élèves
de cette voie qui est souvent porteuse
et notamment en matière
d'insertion professionnel et puis une
question qui touche les programmes pour
vous demander quel est le regard que
vous portez sur les nouveau projets de
programme est-ce qu'ils vous satisfont
et puis j'auraai une dernière question
subsidiaire un petit peu plus ludique
qui concerne le charabia dont nous
gratifient les inspecteurs les
pédagogues de la rue de Grenel car après
le le référentiel bondissant nous avons
droit pour la piscine à cet espace
aquatique standardisé qu'il faut
traverser en équilibre horizontal par
immersion prolongée de la tête est-ce
que c'est pas la meilleure façon de
noyer
l'élève bien merci monsieur le
rapporteur madame
ferrra vous avez la parole merci Madame
m la présidente merci je je crois que ce
matin il était particulièrement
important de de vous entendre les uns et
les autres vous qui est au cœur du
système éducatif alors un point sur
lequel nous sommes tous d'accord la
réussite de nos jeunes est un but très
sérieux et permettez-moi de vous le dire
ne doit pas être sujet à polémique nous
sommes tous conscients qu'il y a
nécessité de de
réformer je ne reviendrai pas sur les
différentes remarques que je par
partage
largement mais
pardonnez-moi avec les réponses en
boucle de la
ministre je voudrais quand même ce matin
m'étonner du du procédé cela a été
évoqué par les uns et les autres le
décret ou l'endemain de la grève le
refus de débattre et l'égalité cette
sacro sainte égalité je crains que ce ne
soit vraiment un jeu de dupe parce que
que feront demain les familles les plus
aisées qui pourront faire appel à des
cours privés et les autres familles ne
pourront que le déplorer et constater
une école à deux vitesses et ce décret
ne règlera rien deux questions
maintenant
euh Jean-Claude Carles l'a déjà évoqué
en ce qui concerne le parcours de
primaire euh moi je suis persuadée qu'il
faudrait en faire un objectif
obligatoire euh à la fin du CM2
c'est-à-dire évidemment avant l'entré en
6e de savoir parfaitement lire et écrire
et compter ce serait ce serait là une
vraie une véritable égalité je voudrais
avoir votre avis là-dessus mais je je
pense le le présentir mais comment
comment conforter cela comment avez-vous
quelques pistes à nous donner dans ce
domaine et puis la deuxième question
concerne l'orientation euh et là aussi
Jean-Claude l'a évoqué certaines
dispositions qui ont été introduites par
le décret sont déjà mises en œuvre dans
l'enseignement agricole euh à l'instar
de l'accompagnement personnalisé ou de
l'autonomie pédagogique qui a fait ses
preuves euh cette autonomie s'y
accompagne d'une vraie autonomie de
gestion je sais que ça a été regretté un
petit peu tout à l'heure et tout cela au
service d'un véritable projet ne
pourrait-on s'en inspirer davantage une
expérience qui fait ses preuves ne peut
qu'être utile par ailleurs et enfin ce
que je regrette et d'ailleurs notre
commission tenté de de travailler sur ce
sujet c'est l'orientation qui reste
l'absent de cette réforme et l'article 6
de l'arrêté qui fait allusion en
prévoyant que les enseignements
pratiques interdisciplinaires les
fameuses epis contribuent à la mise en
œuvre du parcours individuel
d'information d'orientation et de
découverte du monde économique et
professionnel euh vaste programme euh si
ce n'est un projet de référentiel publié
par le Conseil supérieur des programmes
il il y a 6 mois rien n'est prévu pour
sa mise en œuvre et surtout aucun
horaire il me semble-t-il faudra-t-il
donc ponctionner les disciplines pour
organiser ce
parcours bien euh donc un certain nombre
de de questions dont certaines se
recoupent je pense notamment celles sur
l'orientation donc je vais vous vous
donner la parole essayer de la la
répartir peut-être sur certains sujets
certains d'entre vous se soment plus
prêt à à répondre sur peut-être
l'orientation pour prendre le dernier
sujet qui a été évoqué à qui je je donne
la parole allez-y
oui alors sur cette question de
l'orientation euh il se trouve d'une
part effectivement comme le rappelait le
sénateur Carl que la découverte
professionnelle 3h est supprimée par ce
projet de réforme du collège qui était
justement des heures en plus souvent
pour des élèves qui avaient du mal et
qui par la même pouvaient préparer
beaucoup plus efficacement euh la
poursuite euh de leur parcours scolaire
donc de ce point de vue-là il nous
semble que c'est une régression puisque
d'autre part euh on aime bien ça
l'éducation nationale hein les sigles
donc le piod MAP le parcours individuel
d'information d'orientation et de
découverte du monde de l'entreprise
professionnelle ou je ou quelque chose
comme ça économique merci et
professionnel est effectivement mis en
place sur euh les heures disciplinaires
hein et non pas en plus donc donc
c'est-à-dire que c'est quelque chose qui
va devoir se faire sur les heures de
géographie sur les heures de français
sur les heures d'anglais ça ne va pas
venir de surcroix comme pouvait venir
l'option découverte professionnelle 3h
donc de ce point de vue-là c'est très
très clairement une régression d'autant
plus que on en a finalement pas parlé
hein euh l'accompagnement qui est promis
dans cette réforme l'accompagnement
personnalisé euh il faut quand même bien
le savoir qu'il fonctionne comme les EPI
c'est-à-dire qu'il est lui aussi
ponctionné sur les heures disciplinaires
c'est-à-dire qu'il ne va pas y avoir de
l'accompagnement en plus pour les élèves
en difficulté mais qu'un élève en
difficulté qui a 4h3 de français en 6e
je rappelle il en a 5 actuellement il va
s'il a une heure d'accompagnement il va
avoir une heure de français en moins
pour faire cette heure d'accompagnement
alors qu'aujourd'hui il a une heure
d'accompagnement en plus en 6e donc je
vous fait un calcul rapide aujourd'hui
un élève en difficulté dans à peu près
tous les établissements il a 6 heur de
français en 6e en dem il aura 4h3 voilà
donc on en est là donc je ne pense pas
que cette réforme va aider à
l'orientation et notamment à
l'orientation des élèves les plus en
difficulté sur le sujet de l'orientation
madame crper vous souhatiez réagir oui
je voudrais donc effectivement la la
réforme prévoit la disparition de la
Découverte Professionnelle 3h qui était
comme l'a très bien dit mon
collègue réservé entre guillemets ou en
tout cas qui s'adressait très
majoritairement aux élèves pour lesquels
on pensait que une orientation vers la
voie professionnelle serait souhaitable
he de je de la part donc des équipes
pédagogiques il nous paraît nous
essentiel que ce soit tous les
élèves bien tous les élèves qui
découvrent le monde économique et
professionnel et qu'on ne réserve pas la
découverte professionnelle aux seuls
élèves en difficulté dans le collège et
donc seuls élèves qui sont ensuite
orientés vers la voie professionnel par
un choix négatif plutôt que portter par
un projet professionnel positif c'est
pour ça que nous avons milité nous pour
la disparition d'une option facultative
découverte professionnelle 3h et
l'inclusion de la découverte du monde
économique et professionnel dans
l'emploi du temps de tous les élèves de
manière à ce que tous les élèves
puissent préparer correctement leur
orientation le pionmap va trouver des
espaces à la fois dans les disciplines
c'est une des commandes qui a été passée
au Conseil supérieur des programmes les
programmes doivent permettre de dans les
disciplines d'évoquer les débouchés
professionnelles liées aux différents
champs de la connaissance portés par les
disciplines et puis il y a bien sûr le
pays qui
correspondra en partie à ce pionmap qui
s'appelle monde économique et
professionnel il y a donc des espaces
pour tous pour construire l'orientation
je
rappelle au cas où vous l'z oublié que
la découverte professionnelle 6h elle
est maintenue et que donc les classes
qu'on appelle Préa Pro seront maintenus
dans les lycées professionnels pour les
élèves qui ont un projet très
particulier dès la classe de
3e je vous remercie madame
sooger pas bouton Rougeon alors oui
c'est bon merci je voulais juste
rappeler euh pour répondre à la question
de monsieur le sénateur que pour
l'orientation il existe un personnel
qualifié qui s'appelle un conseiller
d'orientation euh conseillère ou
conseiller d'orientation psychologue
qu'on appelle écopsie dont le
recrutement a quand même sérieusement
diminué ces dernières années et aussi il
y a un certain nombre de centre
d'information et d'orientation qu'on
fermé je pense notamment dans le 92 mais
aussi dans le 95 pour ce qui est de la
région parisienne et il me semble pas
que dans les projets du ministère on
prévoit de renforcer ce type de
personnel qui est pourtant le plus
qualifié pour accompagner les élèves
dans leur orientation voilà c'était
juste que je voulais rappeler merci
merci de cette précisiontant donné que
notre commission va engager un travail
de fond et de plusieurs semaine sur le
travail sur la question de l'orientation
alors sur les autres questions notamment
l'apprentissage des fondamentaux la
réduction nombre d'heur consacré aux
enseignements disciplinaires ply madame
euh une précision sur l'orientation on a
les à la FSU le mandat de porter la
scolarité obligatoire à 18 ans ça n'est
pas qu'un un slogan c'est parce que
quand on regarde la réalité euh la
scolarité obligatoire actuelle ne
correspond plus à une organisation du
système éducatif euh plus de 75 % des
élèves entrent au début de 3e à 14 ans
donc à la fin de la 3e par définition
ils n'ont pas 16 ans euh à 16 ans ils
sont pour la majorité donc d'entre eux
déjà au lycée et lorsqu'on regarde ce
qu'on quand on parle de l'orientation
effectivement on ni souvent le travail
que font les conseillers d'orientation
psychologue et qui sont psychologues
parce qu'on sait que le parcours d'un
jeune qui est en train de se construire
qui est en pleine maturation il entre au
collège à 11 ans il en sort à 15 entre
deux il s'est passé un certain nombre de
phénomènes physiologiques psychologiques
et que on a besoin de l'aider et de
l'aider aussi par rapport à une image
que la société peut lui renvoyer de
lui-même qui est quelquefois une image
dévalorisée parce que très vite à quels
sont les élèves que l'on somme de
choisir une orientation ce sont les
élèves des classes populaires les autres
on considère de toute façon qu'ils sont
naturellement amenés à faire des études
des études longues donc il s'agit quand
on parle de l'orientation de faire
attention à ne pas à travers une une
information sur les métiers retrouver en
fait ce que sont des déterminismes
déterminismes sociaux alors quant à la
question du pionmap le problème c'est
que si on ajoute le Peac qui est le
parcours de l'enseignement artistique et
culturel si on ajoute le Pomet on a un
certain nombre de parcours qui
effectivement n'ont pas d'horair
identifié doivent traverser l'ensemble
des disciplines alors on peut trouver
intéressant que ce soit toute la
communauté éducative qui s'empare de ces
parcours sauf que on ne sait pas encore
une fois comment ça peut être mis en
œuvre sans horair identif sans horair
identifiés et sans moyen encore une fois
de concertation dans les équipes
pédagogiques je vous remercie alors sur
les autres questions de nos rapporteurs
je pense en particulier à cette première
question sur la nécessité
d'accentuer les efforts à destination du
primaire les apprentissages fondamentaux
et la pertinence des pays qui souhaite
s'exprimer allez-y Monsieur le
Représentant du snap alors sur le fait
d'accentuer les efforts au primaires et
notamment sur ce qu'on appelle les
fondamentaux ça c'est quelque chose que
nous nous défendons depuis fort
longtemps on l'a bien rappelé alors on a
toujours des batailles de chiffre
là-dessus mais finalement ce qui semble
se révéler c'est qu'au collège les
élèves qui arrivent en difficulté
repartent en difficulté et que de ce
point de vue-là le collège ne corrige
pas euh ça nous sommes bien d'accord
mais une fois encore et là je rejoins
euh je rejoins l'analyse qui est faite
euh il serait déjà bon de faire en sorte
que il y ait pas autant d'élèves qui
arrivent en difficulté à l'entrée au
collège alors suivant les chiffres qu'on
a ça varie suivant toujours le j'allais
dire le critère que l'on prend ça peut
varier souvent à partir don commence
souvent à partir de 20 % il y a déjà eu
des études à l'époque c'était le Haut
Conseil de l'éducation qui arrivait à 40
% d'élèves fragil fragile ou très très
très en difficulté en lecture donc on
est quand même sur des chiffres qui sont
énormes et de ce point de vue-là on a
effectivement eu aucune euh réforme de
fond euh de l'enseignne
primaire sur ces questionsl où on a
plutôt au contraire tendance à ajouter
aux professeurs des écoles des choses en
plus des choses en plus des choses en
plus sur un horaire qui lui en revanche
finalement s'est réduit sur un horaire
d'enseignement qui s'est réduit donc
forcément ça va être assez peu
surprenant qu'à l'arrivée les élèves
soient en difficulté alors il y a des
questions pédagogiques derrière des
questions de formation qui se pose très
très clairement sur ce qui se passe dans
les ESPE comme à l'époque qui se passait
dans les IUFM donc ça ce sont des
questions euh sur l'apprentissage de la
lecture sur l'apprentissage de la
grammaèire sur l'apprentissage du calcul
euh qui sont souvent assez finalement
assez tabou dans le monde de l'éducation
nationale mais que à un moment il va
falloir réellement mettre au premier
plan parce qu'on ne peut pas continuer
avec des élèves qui arrivent en 6e j'en
sais quelque chose puisque j'enseigne au
collège et que j'ai eu de très
nombreuses et j'ai toujours des des
classes en 6e avec des élèves qui
arrivent en 6e et qui sont incapables de
lire un texte euh donc ça on est
parfaitement d'accord sur cette analyse
sur le fait qu'il faut mettre le paquet
au primair sur les fondamentaux sinon on
y arrivera pas et on pourra faire ce
qu'on veut comme réforme du collège ça
ne fonctionnera pas merci Monsieur
monsieur sève vous avez demandé la
parole oui alors d'abord opposer enfin
opposer reporter sur le primaire la le
le la recherche de la solution non je
suis désolé même une école primaire qui
fonctionnerait bien nécessitera as que
l'on repense le collège il y a là mais
je pense qu'on tomberait facilement
d'accord sur ce diagnostic il ne s'agit
pas de dire il faut réformer le primaire
avant où ça nous dispensera de réformer
le collège donc je constate qu'on est
bien d'accord là-dessus donc première
réponse 2uxè deuxème chose les savoirs
fondamentaux alors
premièrement sur les l'enseignement des
disciplines fondamentales puisque c'est
en fait comme ça qu'on pose le problème
j' reviendrai dans un instant sur
l'enseignement des disciplines
fondamentales ou réputé fondamental
sachez quand même que la France est un
des pays est le pas le pays rarement
mais un des pays qui en dispense le plus
au cours de la scolarité c'est qu'on a
un enseignement qui justement
euh consacre aux élèves beaucoup
d'heures d'enseignement 10 fondamentaux
donc on en pense ce qu'on veut on peut
trouver ça très bien mais ne me dites
pas que c'est le manque d'enseignements
fondamentaux qui explique un
différentiel de performance entre
l'enseignement français et les autres
systèmes d'enseignement maintenant moi
je récuse même cette idée d'enseignement
fondamentaux je suis désolé mais parce
qu'en fait on parle de discipline dite
fondamentale or il n'y a pas à mon à ma
connaissance ou à mon sens de discipline
plus fondamentale que les autres
d'ailleurs quand quelqu'un se lance à
cet exercice périlleux qui est de lister
les disciplines fondamentales on aboutit
très rapidement à grosso modo la liste
discipline actuelle du collège hein à
quelques exceptions près donc bon on
voit bien qu'il y a quelque chose dont
on ne sort pas pardonnez-moi je vous
interromp il y a peut-être des
compétences fondamental alors j'y
arriverai j'y arrive justement madame
vous avez parfaitement raison c'est en
terme de compéten fondamentale qu'il
faut raisonner or madame une compétence
une même compétence peut se travailler
dans plusieurs enseignements
disciplinaires elle peut-être l'objectif
c'est le sens d'ailleurs du socle commun
aussi bien celui de 2005 que celui de
2000 quelle anné on est 14 15 je sais
même plus excusez-moi mais c'est le sens
effectivement de préciser les
compétences fondamentales ou pas
d'ailleurs mais les compétences que
toutes les disciplines doivent concourir
à faire acquérir aux élèves donc
discutons effectivement de compétences
fondamentales là il y a sans doute une
discussion intéressante mais ne
transpondons pas à des discussions sur
des disciplines fondamental là c'est
quelque chose qui sans issue bien je
vais passer la parole à nos à nos
collègues parce qu'ils sont nombreux à
vouloir poser des des questions donc par
groupe en commençant par Monsieur
manier merci madame la Présidente bon
j'ai bien entendu ce que nous ont dit
les représentants des différents
syndicats de l'éducation nationale je
les remercie de nous avoir exposé leur
façon de devoir je note d'abord qu'il y
a entre eux et avec nous beaucoup de
points d'accord d'abord et c'est bien
normal nous sommes tous d'accord pour
lutter contre l'échec de ces 150000
jeunes qui sortent chaque année sans
formation du système éducatif c'est tout
à fait inacceptable deuxièmement volonté
de réformer tous long je crois après
c'est une question de de forme
certainement de cette réforme je
rappelle simplement que la refondation
de l'école était une réforme importante
qui a été discutée pendant plusieurs
mois mois et dans laquelle existait bien
le débat sur le collège moi je suis un
peu désolé quand je vois y compris le
président du Sénat qui demande l'ORT de
la réforme sous prétexte qu'elle
n'aurait pas été négocié discuté avec
les organisations syndicales les parents
d'élèves les partenaires elle l'a été
nous avons beaucoup travaillé avec le
ministre payant à l'époque sur la
construction de cette de cette loi du 8
juillet 2013 et je peux vous assurer que
si l'école était la priorité l'école
primaire était la priorité il y avait
bien dans la loi la préoccupation du
collège et bien entendu ce décret qui
arrive aujourd'hui n'est que un décret
pris 2 ans après la loi c'est-à-dire qui
précise qui précise qui avait été
inscrit dans cette loi justement de la
volonté de refonder le collège et en
particulier la mise en place du Conseil
supérieur des programmes qui
effectivement depuis qu'il a été mis en
place travaille sur les programmes du
collège comme il a travaillé
effectivement sur les programmes des
cycles maternel puis ensuite des cycles
de l'école élémentaire alors bien
entendu si on renit si on niit la
nécessité de faire un socle commun de
connaissance de compétences et de
culture dans ce pays il est bien évident
et si on continue à considérer que le
collège est un peu comme le lycée
c'est-à-dire que ce sont les disciplines
qui l'emporte effectivement on ne peut
pas être d'accord sur la méthode
employée mais la volonté de faire ce
sole commun qui va depuis l'entrée de en
cours préparatoire jusqu'à la fin de ce
qui est la 3è c'estàd jusqu'à la fin du
cycle 4 avec la volonté de relier le
collège à l'école élémentaire en mettant
bien le CM2 et la 6e le CP moyen et la
6e dans le même cycle et bien il y a
bien là une une logique et puis nous
sommes aussi tous d'accord sur les
moyens qu'il faut apporter bon tout le
monde je le répéterai pas ici mais c'est
bien dit l'engagement de mettre 60000
postes sur 5 ans face aux 80000 postes
qui ont été supprimés dans les 5 ans
précédents et les 4000 postes qui sont
mis pour cette réforme particulière du
collège sont quand même des moyens qu'il
faut reconnaître je pense qu'ici les uns
et les autres sont d'accord pour pour le
reconnaître alors euh il y a aussi des
points d'accord faut réduire le travail
des élèves bon ça vous le savez comme
moi il travaille il travaillait à
l'école primaire beaucoup trop 6 he par
jour il fallait bien une coupure fallait
trouver un nouveau rythme et au collège
il travaille aussi beaucoup trop en
temps il faut trouver d'autres méthodes
pour pouvoir dans la sans nier l'utilité
d'avoir la place pour toutes les
disciplines et toutes les matières bien
entendu il faut redistribuer et et
travailler différemment travailler en
équipe ça a été dit je ne vais pas
revenir sur le détail donc il y a aussi
des points de désaccord alors point de
désaccord c'est de savoir si cette ce
décret était aussi urgent que cela moi
je crois qu'il fallait préparer la
rentrée 2016 rapidement former les
enseignants donc je ne vais pas prendre
la place de la ministre pour répondre
mais je elle le fera parce que vous
allez discuter ceux qui sont là
aujourd'hui les représentants des
organisations syndicales ont déjà
rencontré les ministres successifs que
ce soit Vincent payon Benoît amamont
aujourd'hui Najad valobcassem et ils
vont elle s'est engagée à discuter
justement pendant cette période de
construction de la circulaire
d'application de de la loi du de ce qui
découle de ce décret et bien il y aura
euh un dialogue permanent et je pense
que même si on n'est pas d'accord sur un
C nombre de choses il y a quand même des
points d'accord qui sont importants
alors les EPI les EPI font débat c'est
évident c'est une nouvelle façon de
travailler euh moi je crois qu'il va
falloir dans nos écoles dans nos
collèges effectivement puisque
semble-t-il qu'il y a toujours de plus
en plus de choses à apprendre il faut
quand même changer les méthodes de
travail et la façon de travailler alors
je ne dis pas que les enseignants euh ne
travaille pas déjà dans ce style là mais
il faut peut-être généraliser alors les
langues vivantes aujourd'hui 100 % des
élèves vont faire deux langues vont
faire une classe bilangue à partir de la
5e je ne vois pas quel danger il peut y
avoir ils vont continuer à travailler le
latin grec dans les cours de littérature
dans les cours où c'est nécessaire donc
il y a à mon avis aucun abandon il y a
simplement une volonté de modifier la
façon de travailler on ne peut pas faire
une réforme ça ne jamais rien changer
sans ne jamais sans vouloir rien mod if
dans la façon de travailler alors moi ce
que j'attendais beaucoup aujourd'hui de
la part des enseignants et on l'a un peu
entendu mais je crois qu'ils le feront
lorsqu'ils débattront avec le ministère
c'est d'apporter leurs propositions
leurs suggestions pour construire
l'école différemment vous savez moi j'ai
été syndicaliste dans les années 70 on
avait à l'époque un seul grande
organisation syndicale que certains
connaissent la feine il y avait un
projet qui s'appelait l'école
fondamental et ce projet d'école
fondamentale il avait ses avantages et s
inconvénients d'ailleurs il a été mis
petit à petit sur pied il a parfois eu
ses échecs mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui
il faut effectivement refonder une
pensée qui soit à la fois politique
sndical sur le façon de faire
fonctionner notre école parce que et
bien l'avenir de nos enfants en dépend
alors je n'ai pas de question à vous
poser simplement et j'ai bien entendu ce
que vous avez dit les uns et les autres
à à vous inciter à à participer au la
poursuite du dialogue la poursuite de la
construction parce que il faut qu'on je
pense que le ministère les élus compte
sur vous je merci merci de de conclure
monsieur manier alors j'ai je je vous
alerte que j'ai SEP demandes de prise de
parole donc il faut que chacun puisse
s'exprimer donc je donne la parole à
Brigitte Gontier main pour le groupe CRC
j'aurais cru m'inscrire plus tard merci
merci pour ce débat merci mesdames
messieurs des organisations syndicales
d'avoir acceptter de de venir nous
rencontrer ce matin je je crois que
c'était utile parce que il faut le dire
qu'il y a eu un certain et moi parmi
parmi ns rangs euh moi je crois que
personne en tout cas je n'ai entendu
personnees dire qu'il ne fallait pas
s'interroger au collège et encore moins
qu'il ne fallait pas le réformer
euh ce qu'il y a c'est que mon sentiment
est que parce que c'est la ce sont les
enseignants qui vont devoir la mettre en
œuvre tout cela ne peut pas se passer
sans un consensus et une une
concertation je vais le dire comme ça
avec la communauté éducative je l'ai dit
dans ma dans ma question d'actualité la
la semaine dernire nière et c'est vrai
qu'il y a eu des échanges dans le cadre
de la loi de refondation et même après
mais des échanges ça ne fait pas sens
quelquefois or je crois qu'une de nos
premières difficultés que nous avons y
compris rencontré lors de la loi de
refondation l'école c'est que y compris
cette loi de refrontation de l'école
avait évidemment suscité beaucoup
d'espoir légitime tant l'école avait été
dégradée par la précédente majorité je
reviens pas dessus
mais que en fait elle ne nous
repositionnait pas sur une visée
d'ambition et que nous ne sortions pas
du séquençage de la manière dont on
abordait les réformes personne personne
n'aurait considérer que il ne fallait
pas avoir des étapes mais nous n'avons
pas pu je crois contribuer à bien
restaurer à donner et à voir qu'était le
sens que nous recherchions à conférer à
l'école et après la question des rythmes
cette nouvelle séquence sur le collège
arrive en fait comme un élément
déstabilisant alors que je confirme
qu'il faut bien réformer euh le le
collège voilà moi je je je suis inquiète
parce que euh si vous voulez j'entends
bien le débat qu'il y a primaire collège
et cetera certes il ne faut pas tout
renvoyer sur le primaire et d'ailleurs
des efforts ont été faits euh en s dans
le sens du primaire puisque notamment on
s'est bataillé je me retourne vers
Françoise Cartron qui est derrière moi
sur la nécessité de restaurer la
question de l'école maternelle et des
des de ans des 2 ans et demi notamment
mais tout cela au fond ne s'est pas
accompagné de la question fondamentale
dont je persiste à croire qu'il faut que
nous la tranchions entre nous qui est la
question du tous capable et on a réussi
à le faire inscrire dans la loi de
refondation mais ça aurait dû
s'accompagner d'une interrogation forte
sur comment on déjoue les difficultés
d'entrer dans les dans les dans les
apprentissages pour certains enfants et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous nous
avançons ça a été dit tout à l'heure
mais nous avançons quand même l'idée que
peut-être il aurait fallu
réenvisager un examen sur toute la
scolarité et y compris en l'allangeant
donc de revoir pas simplement la
question du rythme à la semaine mais
d'envisager une réforme des rythmes
complet pour donner du temps à l'enfant
qui a besoin de remédiation on voit le
bilan du lycée professionnel ramené de 4
à 3 ans il y a besoin de temps parce que
tout le monde si tout le monde est
capable d'apprendre tout le monde
n'entre pas dans les pratissage au même
rythme parce que il y a qui dès le début
entre dès l'école maternelle avec la
possibilité de comprendre des codes mais
d'autres il faut il faut il faut donc le
faire et ça ça m'amène donc au-delà de
la question de de de d'un examen sur une
réorganisation de
l'organisation scolaire et des rythmes
scolaires sur la question de la
formation qui a été complètement laminée
que la nouvelle majorité s'est engagé à
reconstruire euh de mon point de vue pas
suffisamment forte puisque la question
du prérecrutement est est ignorée mais
alors il nous demeure une question
fondamentale c'est celle de la formation
continue dont la ministre me répond la
semaine dernière qu'il va y avoir des
moyens de mobiliser mais
voyez enfin quelle arme on donne à ces
hommes et ces femmes à ce métier dont on
sait qu'il est dans une grande
souffrance parce que mes chers collègues
tous les jours ils retroussent leurs
manches pour pour essayer d'amortir les
successions de réformes qui ne cessent
de leur tomber dessus depuis 40 ans et
qui essaent
d'amortir sur le terrain les les
difficultés donc il y a un engagement il
y a un potentiel d'écoute dans ce métier
formidable mais il faut il faut y
répondre donc moi je ne suis pas mes
chers collègues juste r la parle imement
main je vous la rends immédiatement
juste vous dire profitons que nous ayons
des invités pour bien sûr nous exprimer
mais leur poser questions leur poser des
questions alors moi je je pose des
questions je pose des questions comment
est-ce que moi je dis il faut allonger
le temps de
scolarité en même temps on voit bien que
on vient on vient d'ouvrir une question
sur
l'interdisciplinarité et sur le fait
qu'il y aurait plus d'autonomie laissé
au chefs d'établissement donc il y a
comme une contradiction si vous voulez
en le fait dans le sens où on a besoin
de de réorganiser avec plus de souplesse
mais où en même temps on peut se se
trouver engagé dans une forme de
concurrence liée à l'établissement et
donc un problème d'égalité
d'organisation du système scolaire
national public sur l'ensemble du du
territoire voilà ma question merci
Madame Gontier main je donne la parole
maintenant à Madame bouchou pour le
groupe écologiste euh madame la
Présidente mes chers collègues je vais
essayer de pas vous faire un long tunnel
sur ce que je pense parce que je pense
que ça n'a pas forcément grand intérêt
je vais essayer de poser des questions à
nous invités que je remercie de leur
contribution euh une question sur un
point que j'ai mal entendu ou peut-être
est une initation de ma part quid du du
plaisir d'apprendre quit du bonheur de
progresser est-ce que vous ne pensez pas
tous qu'en fait maintenant on est plus
tellement obligé de chercher des
problèmes mais plutôt essayer
d'apprendre à travailler autrement là
j'ai l'impression que depuis 2h on fait
comme si on était encore au je sais pas
début du 20e siècle le monde le monde
d'avant donc les les enfants c'est comme
des oies il suffit de les G si ça rentre
bien avec les bonnes heures et cetera ça
va faire des choses formidables donc je
me demandais où est le plaisir
d'apprendre où est
le alors où est le plaisir d'apprendre
où est le plaisir de progresser et
excusez-moi mais il y a ceux qu'on
entend jamais c'est les élèves donc moi
j'ai le tort de passer mon temps aller
dans les établissements scolaires de
voir des petits des grands des moyens et
il y a une chose dont il parle beaucoup
il y a ceux qui sont malheureux parce
qu'ils n'y arrivent pas donc c'est la
hentise du classement il y a ceux aussi
je vous le dis franchement quel que soit
le milieu social qui s'ennuie à mourir
alors ça c'est le tabou faut pas dire
qu'il y en a qui s'ennuit à l'école
c'est pas bien et cetera et dernière
chose d'autres choses dont on parle
c'est le climat scolaire c'est-à-dire
c'est la difficulté avec les incivilités
les règles de vie communes et cetera et
donc là nous on avait proposé dans la
loi euh des modules de de de gestion non
violente des conflits je signale que ça
existe dans combien d'établissements ça
a été mis en place dans combien
d'espects concrètement on a mis en place
ces modules je me pose la question et
dernier point c'est un peu ironique de
ma part je pense que notre avis de
chacun n'est pas forcément en lié à la
place qu'il occupe sur ce banc mais
peut-être au bonheur qu'il a eu ou pas
d'apprendre au rapport qu'on a eu à
l'apprentissage et dire qu'à ceux qui
craindrai que cette réforme ne remplisse
les établissements privés que c'est fort
de café parce que moi je viens d'un
département où on a autant de privé que
de public et je peux vous dire que ça
dans le privé ça existe depuis longtemps
l'autonomie et cetera la seule chose la
seule chose donc là je réponds au
représentant du snalk je réponds aussi à
ma collègue qui a raison de
l'enseignement agricole les tris/4s des
choses proposées dans ce texte sont des
choses qui marchent dans l'enseignement
public agricole depuis 5 ans il serait
mort depuis longtemps si on avait pas
fait ça donc la question est la suivante
c'est quand est-ce qu'on va arrêter de
défendre sa matière sa discipline sa
classe et défendre tous ensemble les
élèves le plaisir d'apprendre et le
bonheur de travailler
merci merci Madame bouchou madame
Laborde pour le groupe
RDSE merci madame la Présidente tout
d'abord je vous prie de m'excuser si je
pose une ou deux questions où il y a
déjà eu les réponses puisque j'étais pas
tout à fait à l'heure donc je vous prie
de m'en excuser
donc c'est vrai que nous avons donc des
questions cribles demain avec la
ministre et ça nous permettra bah
d'avoir des réponse de la ministre et
c'est vrai que cette rencontre
aujourd'hui nous permet d'affiner
nos déjà par rapport à vous
enseignant nos nos questionnements donc
bon il y a déjà des choses qui ont été
dites moi c'est vrai que je m'inquiète
sur la formation continue parce que pour
être prêt en septembre 2016 c'est
peut-être pas très facile quand on voit
le niveau de de formation continue quand
je dis le niveau c'est l'engagement et
les possibilités de formation c'est pas
le niveau la réussite bien sûr euh j'ai
une question en effet moi sur le le
prioritairement que dé
dououblés puisque si c'est au choix de
des uns et des autres est-ce que l'on va
favoriser donc justement des des aides
personnalisées comme vous disiez tout à
à l'heure dans des classes dédoublé ou
des aides personnalisées à 26 ou 27 ou
28 ou 30 c'est peut-être un petit peu
compliqué et j'ai aussi une question euh
puisque si j'ai bien regardé en 6e il y
aura 26h donc au total euh de de cours
pour les enfants de présence hein re
personnalisé comprise et euh avec
une un maximum par jour de 6h et avec
une coupure obligatoire d' 1h30 c'est
rajouté sauf dérogation donc déjà ça me
hérisse un peu parce que nous parlions
des écoles privées j'espère que les
écoles privées sous contrat ne seront
pas autorisés à déroger et et donc c'est
c'est pour moi une question très
importante est-ce qu'on est capable dans
tous les Collège de France de mettre en
place ces 26 heures sans dérogation et
j'ai une autre question par rapport à
l'histoire géographie et éducation
civique d'avant qui devient
histoiregéographie
enseignement moral et civique nous
avions 3 heures et les professeurs
d'histoire géographie avouaient souvent
que l'éducation civique permettait
parfois de de finir le
programme il en sera de même pour
l'éducation morale et civique je suppose
ou alors il faut aussi être assez
directif voilà mes deux questions merci
Madame labord donc l'ensemble des
groupes sétant exprimé il y aura
d'autres questions juste après je
redonne la parole à nos invités donc sur
ces questions précises qui souhaitent
répondre madame crperè allez-y
oui tout d'abord revenir sur la notion
de d'adhésion des personnels à la
réforme de consensus de
concertation madame Gautier Morin c'est
s'est inquiété hein de du fait que les
enseignants ne sont pas forcément pour
l'instant favorable à cette réforme on a
vu effectivement qu'il y a eu un
mouvement social
bon on va pas dire important mais
visible hein dans les établissements
donc il y a effectivement là un travail
à faire euh pour ma part en tant que
responsable national de mon syndicat
j'anime des stages dans les académies et
je rencontre les collègues et je peux
vous dire que quand on leur parle de la
réforme sans vouloir leur faire peur
quand on leur montre les clés de la
réforme et en particulier qu'on leur
montre comment eux pourront utiliser les
marges d'autonomie pour porter leur
projets et en particulier porter les
projets en faveur des élèves les plus en
difficulté ils en ressorte rassuré et
enthousiasmé donc il est tout à fait
possible de faire adhérer les
enseignants à cette réforme encore
faut-il la présenter de manière positive
ce qui n'est pas pour l'instant souvent
le cas dans les réunions syndicales
auxquelles ils assistent sur l'autonomie
du chef d'établissement et la
concurrence alors d'abord souligner que
la concurrence entre les établissements
elle existe déjà de fait elle est même
très marquée dans certains territoires
et je ne parle pas de la concurrence
entre le prix privé et le public je
parle de la concurrence entre les
établissements publics par l'offre de
par l'offre
de d'option on crée très clairement des
concurrences marquées entre les
établissements la réforme donnant
beaucoup moins de place à toutes ces
options facultatives réduisant le poids
du facultatif réduit de fait la
concurrence entre les
établissements de de cette manière quant
à l' autonomie du chef d'établissement
oui elle sera de fait une autonomie du
chef d'établissement chaque fois que les
équipes enseignantes ne s'engageront pas
de manière résolue dans les conseils
pédagogiques et dans les conseils
d'administration pour porter leurs idées
et leur projet donc il faut bien
redonner ce pouvoir d'agir aux
enseignants leur dire qu'il faut qu'ils
s'en
saisissent pour ne pas être
effectivement ensuite s'ils ne s'en
saisissent pas simplement des exécutant
de projets qui auront été construits par
d'autres le plaisir d'apprendre et bien
nous espérons effectivement que nous
allons retrouver ou redonner du plaisir
d'apprendre et en tout cas le donner à
tous hein parce qu'il y en a qui ont du
plaisir d'apprendre dans nos dans nos
classes mais il y a aussi beaucoup
d'élèves qui n'en ont pas et c'est
important de leur donner du plaisir
d'apprendre nous pensons nous que les
programmes tels qu'ils sont pour
l'instant en cours d'élaboration bien
sûr il y a des points voir mais il y a
beaucoup de choses qui vont dans le sens
de donner du plaisir d'apprendre parce
que on redonne la place à la
découverte à la découverte des savoirs
avec les élèves et par les élèves et
puis un point très important c'est
l'évaluation le poids de l'évaluation
pour l'instant évaluation qui sert
beaucoup au classement et pas beaucoup à
identifier quels sont les acquis réel de
nos élèves euh cette évaluation doit
bouger et pour nous c'est un des
incontournables de la réforme si
l'évaluation ne bouge pas nous n'aurons
pas les les nous ne réussirons pas cette
réforme et nous ne permettrons pas à
tous les élèves d'adhérer aux
apprentissages le climat scolaire juste
un mot sur le climat scolaire un des
facteurs
important de dégradation du climat
scolaire c'est la ségrégation interne
dans les établissements euh il n'y a pas
pire violence dans un établissement que
de voir une classe où son euh regrouper
ensemble tous les bons élèves et une
autre classe où sont regroupés ensemble
tous les élèves faibles surtout dans
certains quartier où
euh les les regroupements sont
malheureusement souvent aussi visibl du
point de vue des euh ethniques et
entraîne des conflits très importants
dans nos
établissements Éric de Barbieux qui
travaille beaucoup avec les
établissements où le climat scolaire est
dégradé euh travaille à faire entendre
cela et travaille à la à la constitution
des de classe véritablement hétérogène
où on n'utilise pas justement les
enseignements facultatifs pour regrouper
les élèves en fonction de leur prétendu
niveau scolaire et euh et donc mettre
fin à ces pratiques ségrégatives c'est
améliorer le climat scolaire de manière
très importante voilà je vous remerci je
laisse répondre mes collègues sur la
formation continue parce qu'il y a
beaucoup d'jeux aussi sur
allez-y oui alors je vais essayer d'être
synthétique sur les choses qui ont été
euh signalées tout d'abord je tiens
quand même à repartir sur la question de
la loi de refondation la loi de
refondation ne prévoyait pas
spécifiquement cette réforme du collège
d'ailleurs la réforme que nous nous
proposons depuis 2 ans s'inscrit
parfaitement dans le texte de la loi de
refondation donc la loi de refondation
ne prévoyait pas par exemple de
supprimer les classe bilangue de
supprimer les Européennes de diminuer
l'horaire de latin c'est pas marqué du
tout dans la loi de refondation ça elle
ne prévoyait pas que les enseignements
complémentaires que sont les EPI et
l'accompagnement personnalisé soi pris
sur les heures disciplinaires non plus
c'est pas non plus marqué dans la loi de
refondation donc à partir de cette loi
de refondation très large on peut
imaginer des réformes du collège et il
nous semble que celle qui a été imaginé
n'est pas bonne sur la question du privé
euh alors effectivement le privé sous
contrat bien entendu et supposer
appliquer euh cette réforme sauf donc je
je le signale pour la question que
posait M madame la sénatrice sur les
questions horaires c'est-à-dire que le
privé n'a pas à se confirmer aux
contraintes horaires euh sur la pause
méridienne ou sur le maximum de 6h de
même qu'il n'a pas à se conformer à la
réforme des rythmes scolaires ce qui
d'ailleurs offre un certain différentiel
dans certaines zones aux établissements
aux écoles privées de ce point de vue
euh le privé fonctionne en mode
dérogatoire ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
pas de privé sous-crat en France nous on
défend les enseignants du privé
sous-contrat également mais il faut bien
voir qu'effectivement il fonction sur un
mode dérogatoire qui sélectionne ses
élèves à l'entrée dans un certain nombre
de cas dans beaucoup de cas que
effectivement il peut les exclure et
qu'il va pas s'en récupérer d'autres en
échange par exemple donc de ce point de
vue-là ça nous paraît très très
compliqué d'aller faire une sorte de
comparaison privé public nous ce que
nous voyons surtout c'est que les
établissements privés même s'ils sont
supposés appliquer ce décret cet arrêté
dispose un certain nombre de cas de
moyens propres dispose de manières de
contourner qui vont leur permettre de
proposer ce que l'école publique ne
proposera plus et de ce point de vue-là
ça va renforcer ce qui existe déjà
c'est-à-dire une forme de ségrégation
social privé public qui ne peut aller
qu'en sa croissant puisque effectivement
l'offre va être vraiment distingué entre
ce qui est dans le public notamment dans
les zones les plus défavorisées où c'est
justement parce qu'on a ces dispositif
parce qu'on a ces options parce qu'on a
ces sections qu'un certain nombre de
familles de classe sociale plus favorisé
reste dans le public et ça demain ils
n'y resteront pas sur la question sur
l'histoiregéographie il y a pas eu de
changement d'horaire ou de
fonctionnement c'est-à-dire qu'en gros
l'enseignement moral et civique prend
effectivement la place de l'éducation
civique les programmes qui sont encore
en cours de consultation pour nous ne
nous conviennent pas sur un certain
nombre de points donc un nombre de
points majeurs notamment sur les
disciplines qu'on appellera ou non
fondamental le débat reste ouvert du
français des mathématiques où il nous
semble qu'on est en régression sur ce
que les élèves vont pouvoir apprendre et
vont pouvoir maîtriser dans ces
disciplines
là
euh dernière réponse avant que je
redonne la parole aux collègues allez-y
madame S merci alors sur l'autonomie
laissé au chefs d'établissement donc
c'est vrai que la réforme permet qu'en
gros 20 % de la dotation horaire soit
décidé donc par le chef d'établissement
mais bien sûr sur appui du CA et du
projet d'établissement donc la question
qu'on peut se poser c'est comment
qu'est-ce qui va se passer pour les les
disciplines qui vont à qui on va
attribuer les marges en fait d'horaire
et c'est ça quand on parle de mise en
concurrence des discipline c'est pas les
collègues qui mettent en concurrence la
discipline ici c'est ce que prévoit la
réforme et c'est notre inquiétude à qui
on va attribuer ses marges horaires à
qui on va attribuer les
dédoublements donc je pour répondre à la
question de sur les dédoublements de la
sénatrice c'est vrai voilà plusieurs
professeurs peuvent tout à fait demander
à avoir des dédoublements dans leur
classe en estimant que pour certaines
discip ou pour le profil de la classe et
dédoublement sont tout à fait utiles
mais là ça ne sera plus vraiment
possible puisque comme c'est une réforme
qui est faite à moyen constant on n pas
de moyens supplémentaires je pense par
ailleurs à ce qui a été dit sur les
langues tout à l'heure monsieur sénateur
disait oui 100 % des élèves maintenant
vont être en classe bilang alors c'est
pas tout à fait vrai puisqu'en terme
d'horaire il y a une diminution que la
classe bilangue c'était dès la 6e avec
3h LV1 3h év2 là on revient à partir de
la 5e avec 2h30 hein de LV2 pour être
professeur de langue je peux vous dire
que en dessous de TR 3 He
l'apprentissage de la langue reste très
difficile hein et n'est pas à mon avis
suffisant au lycée on l'a bien vu on a 2
heures maintenant en terminale en
première de LV2 ça reste très compliqué
pour préparer au bac enfin c'est juste
une parenthèse mais je voilà je voulais
le préciser donc on parlait des savoirs
tout à l'heure fondamentaux bon c'est
qu'à mon avis on confond les
connaissances et les compétences on
parle du plaisir d'apprendre développer
des compétences sans avoir de
connaissance ça ne me semble pas
possible hein développer un savoirfaire
sans savoir ce n'est pas possible non
plus hein c'est là qu'on parlait de base
le primaire la diminution des horaires
hebdomadaires de français si on reprend
dans la scolarité obligatoire en
français donc pour collège et primairire
c'était 78 he de français en 1977 c'est
passé à 53 he au 2011 donc je vois pas
comment même un élève peut avoir envie
d'apprendre si on lui donne pas les
connaissances et les moyens et par
ailleurs que les professeurs mettent en
place des projets interdisciplinairees
c'est quelque chose d'ailleurs qui se
fait sur les établissements déjà nous on
n'est pas contre l'interdisciplinaire
non plus nfolc mais c'est vrai que c'est
d'autant mieux quand c'est sur la base
du volontariat on parlait de des des des
des enseignants qui s'éclatent vous
avveit dit euh dans ce qu'ils font bah
ils le feront aussi par choix et parce
qu'ils ont les moyens de le faire et pas
parce qu'on leur a enlevé des heures
disciplinaires pour le faire nous au
lycée on a les enseignements
d'exploration depuis la réforme du lycée
hein il se trouve que souvent ces
enseignements d'exploration peu de
collègues veulent les faire veulent les
mettre en place et les élèves demandent
parfois mais qu'est-ce que c'est que cet
enseignement il y a pas de programme il
y a pas de notes qu'est-ce qu'on va
qu'est-ce qu'on va y faire les cadres ce
n'est pas c'est structurant un cadre je
pense et c'est ça qui nous permet
d'avancer donc sur l'interdisciplinarité
ponctionner sur les horaires
disciplinaires ça me semble pas la
solution or c'est ce qui est prévu dans
la réforme du collège je vous remercie
bien Monsieur S et Madame Rollet pour
une réponse oui on va essayer de faire
conè question non ben je vais du coup ne
pas répondre à tous les toutes les
questions d'autant que des choses ont
été dites juste quand même revenir sur
la d'abord sur la concurrence entre
établissement et même autonomie bon
claire creper a très bien dit que la
concurrence existe déjà je pas en
français il y aurait pas de carte
scolaire où on ne se poserait pas la
question de la carte scolaire s'il y
avait pas déjà la concurrence entre
établissement concurrence de fait le but
ou du moins l'objectif me semble-t-il
pour diminuer cette concurrence c'est
bien de faire réusir tous les élèves de
telle sorte que être avec le fils ou la
fille de tel milieu social plutôt
queêtre avec le fils ou la fille
excusez-moi la fille ou le fils je quand
même permuter de tel autre milieu social
n'a pas d'importance c'est ça qu'il faut
viser c'est en en faisant réussir tout
les élèves c'est là qu'on fera tomber la
la concurrence entre établissements
parce que le choix de l'établissement
sera plus un critère de réussite donc
c'est bien ça vers quoi alors la
question c'est est-ce que c'est possible
ou pas là je dis très objectivement
effectivement on peut d'un d'un côté ou
de l'autre de de l'chiqué répondre de
façon différente hein mais le fond du
fond c'est ça si on estime possible de
faire réussir tous les élèves alors en
faisant réussir tous les élèves on fera
tomber la concurrence en établissement
et c'est pas une option ou je ne sais
quel dispositif qui sera qui est
vraiment à la base C de la concurrence
entre les disciplines moi je excusez-moi
mais je ne crois pas alors bien entendu
tous les collègues si moi on m'avait
posé est-ce que tu veux que tu es classe
soit dédoublé est-ce que tu veux plus de
pour faire ceci plus j'aurais sûrement
dit oui effectivement mais je revendique
aussi pour moi quand j'étais en
situation et pour mes collègues qui le
sont tout de même le droit de me mettre
d'accord avec mes autres collègues de
l'équipe éducative moi je n'ai pas connu
d'établissement où les collègues ne sont
pas capables de se mettre d'accord
effectivement sur et bien le partage par
exemple deur dédoublé effectivement
quand on confisque ce choix alors
effectivement tout le monde est con
c'est la seule façon si le choix est
confisqué par le par le chef
d'établissement par ailleurs ou par
quelconque autorité effectivement chacun
est renvoyé à sa situation personnelle
et il y a pas de collégialité pas
décision collégiale donnons au collègues
la possibilité de décider ensemble
quelque chose et vous verrez il y aura
pas tant de concurrence que ça entre les
collègues donc la concurrence entre les
disciplines c'est un bon argument pour
encore une fois ne rien faire et ça
dissimule une espèce de de de méfiance
vis-à-vis des collègues qui moi j'avoue
me me gêne un peu de même quand on
oppose à quand on critique l'autonomie
mais qu'on invoque sans arrêt le
volontariat je me dis il y y a quelque
chose qui cloche moi effectivement je
suis pour le volontariat mais le
volontariat généralisé le volontariat
reconnu c'est ce que j'appelle
l'autonomie des équipes
éducatives merci ensuite juste une
dernière chose excusez-moi mais je
revendique aussi pour mes collègues
alors ça fait pendant à ce que je viens
de dire sur la capacité de s'entendre
mais le droit au dissensus le droit au
débat je ne pense pas qu'il faille
attendre un consensus entre les
collègues pour faire quelque chose
d'autant que avec l'échantillon que l'on
vous donne aujourd'hui vous aurez bien
compris que ça sera relativement
difficile au moins pour H d'entre eux
mais je revendique pour les collègues le
droit de ne pas être d'accord et de se
mettre d'accord Infiné localement en
équipe ça n'est pas à nous ça n'est même
pas à nous organisation syndical de
décider sur quoi les collègues doivent
se mettre d'accord donc derrière ces
questions là qui il y a quel il y a une
vision du métier une vision de la
professionnalité enseignant qu' va
falloir restaurer excusez-moi le le
terme
merci merci Madame Rollet oui
j'essaierai d'être rapide je repartirai
d'abord de la question du dialogue
social euh ce gouvernement a fait du la
du dialogue social son marqueur c'est
été un discours fort du président de la
République lors de son investiture or
quand on fait une réforme de la santé on
écoute les médecins lorsqu'on fait une
réforme de la justice on écoute les les
magistrats alors j'entends ce que dit
monsieur manier sur la loi de
refondation les syndicats de la FS ont
très largement participé aux discussions
sur la loi de refondation sur les décrit
enseignant sur le socle commun
effectivement la loi de refondation dit
des choses alors pour qu'il n'y ait pas
d'ailleurs de de polémique sur les
chiffres je vous invite à relire ce que
disent ce que dit le rapport annexé de
la loi refondation qui dit très
clairement euh 25 % des élèves arrivrive
au collège à la sortie de l'école
primaire avec des acquis euh fragile et
dont 15 % avec des difficultés très
sévères et les écarts se creusent entre
le groupe des plus forts et le groupe
des plus faibles le problème est que le
collège n'arrive pas à enrayer ce ce
phénomène créer d'autres formes
d'inégalité donc nous tombons bien
d'accord qu'il faut une une réforme et
qu' une réforme qui tende vers plus
d'égalité là-dessus je pense que il faut
éviter toute toute polémique et toute
caricature mais alors ensuite une fois
qu'on a un cadre et qu'on a fixé des
objectifs
on sait que faire une réforme aussi
complexe et qui va engager toute une
génération suppose quand même un temps
de concertation suffisamment long et de
prendre divers avis je parlais par
exemple du Conseil supérieur des
programmes qui a eu le sentiment de ne
pas être écouté mais pour nous qui
représentons quand même ensemble une
majorité des enseignants alors sauf à
considérer que le syndicalisme ne sert
plus à rien en France mais enfin bon je
pense pas que ce soit un atout pour qui
que ce soit et bien bien euh on a eu en
tout et pour tout je disais trois
séquences de trois séances pardon de
concertation et un décret qui est sorti
un jour Donon ne sa où sans que il en
ait jamais été question alors on peut
considérer que tous les enseignants sont
d'affreux immobilistes mais à un moment
enfin quand vous avez un mouvement fort
puisque bon chacun sait les polémiques
sur la comptabilisation des des gréistes
mais enfin quand on dit qu'il y a eu un
enseignant sur de collège croyez-moi y
compris les recteurs me l'ont confirmé
donc ça n'est pas ça n'est pas un rêve
et bien ça a un sens ça a un sens
pourquoi parce que Madame Gon l'a dit on
a des collègues qui tous les jours
travaillent dans leurs établissements
font beaucoup d'effort et qui ont le
sentiment là de ne pas être écouté alors
sur la loi de sur l'interdisciplinarité
d'abord évitons là aussi les caricatures
elle se fait déjà qu'est-ce que
l'histoire des arts sinon de
l'interdisciplinarité euh est-ce que
l'interdisciplinarité suppose forcé
euh de se faire dans les conditions qui
qui sont imposées non est-ce que le la
pédagogie de projet ser se réduit à
l'interdisciplinarité non donc nous
récusons cette idée d'abord du faire
certains élèves en gros et ceux des
classes populaires notamment de façon
sous-jacente il y a cette idée qu'il
serait incapable de relever certains
défis intellectuels et que et bien on
oppose le faire et le penser ils peuvent
pas penser on va leur faire faire euh
c'est pas comme ça qu'on amène tout le
monde à entrer dans une culture commune
alors il faut poser la question
effectivement comment on on aide
beaucoup mieux comment on prend le temps
de faire entrer tous les élèves dans des
apprentissages formateurs la question du
temps là aussi elle a été évoquée moi je
il y a des choses qui me surprennent
dans les contradictions monsieur Manet
dit les élèves travaillent ils ont trop
de ils passent trop de temps à l'école
euh ils sont euh ils sont c'est trop
long et en même temps quand vous
regardez tout ce que disent enfin la
majorité des chercheurs en
senceéducation il nous dis c'est à
l'école qu'on diminue le plus les
inégalités on sait que plus on réduit le
temps scolaire et plus on reporte sur
les familles les euh les on reporte les
difficultés donc justement il aurait
mieux fallu penser comment on travaille
le temps global de l'élève la question
de la vie scolaire on met une heure 1
heure méridienne au collège très bien
euh simplement moi ça fait 20 ans que je
suis enseignante en collège les élèves
sont venus me dire bah oui mais madame
nous on mange en 20 minutes à la cantine
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire pendant 1h3 euh
on a absolument rien penser en terme de
dispositifs qui permettent justement
d'avoir des activités qui soient qui
soient formatrices donc il y a toute une
série de sujets sur la les fausses
questions
de élitisme ou dispositif élitisme enfin
soyons soyons honnête entre nous la
mixité sociale nous la souhaitons une
mixité sociale et scolaire elle passe
par une refonte de la carte scolaire
elle passe par une refonte de la carte
d'implantation des options des langues
euh parce qu'autrement on sait très bien
hein que des parcours d'initiés ça se
recrée quels que soient les dispositifs
donc et l'idée que les classes les
sections bilang euh vous prenez les
collèges du 20e à Paris il y a pas de
classe bilang et dans les dans dans les
gros collèges les élèves sont répartis
sur l'ensemble des divisions de 6e et ça
crée une certaine émulation donc c'est
plutôt comme ça qu'il fallait travailler
comment on faisait pour justement rendre
plus attractif il y a eu un premier pas
avec l'éducation prioritaire mais très
insuff dis an comment on fait pour
rendre plus attractif l'ensemble des
établissements donc c'est toutes ces
questions qui devaient être travaillées
nous n'avons pas pris le temps de le
faire on a des enseignants maintenant
qui dans leur grande majorité refusent
cette cette réforme parce qu'ils disent
elle n'aura aucun bénéfice pour les
élèves vous êtes dans le cycle 4 cycle 4
c'est 5e 4e 3e tous les élèves doivent
avoir une heure d'accompagnement
personnalisé certes euh qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire euh on va faire une heure
chaque semaine où on dira écoutez on
vous met 28 dans la classe et puis on
vous fait de l'accompagnement
personnalisé ça veut dire quoi ça n'a
pas fonctionné au lycée on n en a pas
tiré de bilan d'ailleurs le retard qui
est pris sur un examen de la réforme des
lycées est assez significatif euh et
bien encore une fois là aussi beaucoup
de questions donc pourquoi je vais vous
demander de conclure Mad VO exactement
mais ma question c'est pourquoi
n'écouteons pas les professionnels aussi
euh euh qui justement son mett voilà non
mais de table ronde donc j'ai quatre
demandes de prise de parole madame mélo
madame Cartron Monsieur groserin Madame
Gillot je vous indique que nous avons
une deuxième table ronde qui commence
dans 10 minutes donc je vais contrainte
de vous contraindre à vous exprimer avec
concision alors madame Méo merci madame
la Présidente bon tout ce qui a été dit
est fort intéressant mais bon je
voudrais bon dire que le diagnostic nous
le partageons je crois que on ne peut
que dire qu'il est il est vraiment
inacceptable que
150000 jeunes qui le le système scolaire
sans sans qualification et qu'il faut
réformer notre système éducatif mais
comment l'autonomie c'est c'est vrai que
c'est un un sujet qui se pose et
d'autant plus que bon notre population a
changé les besoins sont devenus
différents et bon pour ma part je pense
que le collège unique a vécu s'il a été
légitime en 1975 il n certainement il ne
l' certainement plus aujourd'hui euh
l'un de vous a évoqué un collège
modulaire je pense que c'est un un choix
pertinent et je voudrais savoir s'il y a
eu des résultats si on peut bon en en
tirer quelques quelques conséquences
euh le collège modulaire donc bon
prévoit je suppose un socle commun le
SOC commun certes il est il est
important il doit être d'ailleurs
stabilisé dès la fin de de l'école
élémentaire mais il faut aussi une offre
différente il faut savoir lire écrire
compter mais il faut aussi
savoir avoir une une initiation à
d'autres sujets pour pouvoir ensuite
faire des choix pour
pouvoir révéler les aptitudes de tous
les élèves parce que je pense que tous
ont des aptitudes seulement on les on
les laisse dans un carcan et ils ne
peuvent pas euh ils ne peuvent pas se se
révéler et savoir de quoi ils sont
capables hein une de nos collègues a dit
que beaucoup de d'élèves n'étaient pas
heureux mais oui ils ne sont pas heureux
parce qu'on leur impose certaines choses
et ils ne peuvent pas entre guillemets
s'éclater dans dans ce qu'ils aimeraient
faire et dans ce qu'il pourraent faire
je vais m'arrêter donc l'égalité des
chances n'est pas n'est pas n'est pas un
le but qui est recherché par cette
réforme et je voudrais dire dire un un
dernier mot sur la suppression des
classes européennes et des classes
bilangues parce que dire que les élèves
bon ça a été dit avant que je le disent
pourront apprendre de langues c'est faux
j'ai été professeur de langue moi aussi
dans une vie antérieure il est
absolument faux qu'en faisant
2h3 d'une langue 2h3 d'une autre qu'on
va apprendre cette langue c'est faux
donc les classes européennes ouvreit les
élèves à un un horizon culturel
différent et j'ai eu l'expérience iance
de classes européennes dans un dans un
un établissement de de zone d'éducation
prioritaire et c'était vraiment très
très très satisfaisant les élèves
pouvaient vraiment obtenir de bons
résultats et ont pu continuer un
parcours alors qu'il y a 50 % de
boursiers dans l'établissement c'est
quand même un critère à prendre en
compte donc là on laisse au bord de la
route les zones urbaines sensibles euh
je crois que en voulant donner le les le
même enseignement à tous et bien on
laisse de côté peut-être les enfants qui
mériterit de d'être aidé et d'avoir un
enseignement différent merci Madame
Cartron euh oui madame la Présidente euh
j'ai j'ai le sentiment et là sur la
conclusion de Madame Méot que souvent on
raisonne sur des contresens
oui non mais parce que dire que
aujourd'hui dans les zones d'éducation
prioritaire euh bah écoutez on donne
toutes les chances à tous les élèves et
que demain avec cette réforme on en
donnera moins ça je pense que c'est une
erreur d'analyse totale parce que ce qui
a été soulevé pardon ce qui a été
soulevé quand même dans les constats de
de l'échec de ces 150000 jeunes c'est
quand même l'inégalité entre les
établissements et l'inégalité au sein
des établissements entre justement euh
certaines classes et d'autres et les
jeunes et les enfants en non conscience
et aujourd'hui on l'a pas évoqué mais
euh après les les les les les malheureux
euh incidents et plus qu'incidents du du
11 janvier on s'est posé la question
qu'est-ce qui fait sens qu'est-ce qui
fait République et et quelle est la
place de notre école et bien je crois
que l'école elle ne peut faire sens et
République que si elle-même et si les
enfants ont conscience que la République
est là pour eux de manière égale et
c'était le sens de la loi de refondation
de l'école c'est là que je dis ceux qui
ont aujourd'hui ne comprennent pas cette
réforme des collèges je pense qu'ils
n'ont pas compris qui était le sens de
la refondation de l'école l'axe
essentiel qui était une école qui
accueille tous les enfants et qui donne
à chaque enfant la possibilité d'aller
le plus loin possible et le plus haut
possible à l'opposé d'une école qui trie
d'une école qui ségrègue une une école
qui classifie et donc une école qui
exclut donc ça c'était l'axe l'ADN de la
loi de refondation de l'école alors
aujourd'hui on nous dit il y a pas eu de
concertation ce qui décl ce qui est
décliné par rapport à la à la à la
réforme des collèges est bien évidemment
contenu dans cette loi de refondation de
l'école néanmoins et donc je vais en
venir à ma première question néanmoins
nous sommes là désormais avec le décret
dans les modalités d'application et de
mise en œuvre de cette réforme et de de
cette réforme des collèges et donc je
pose la question à à l'ensemble des
représentants
syndicaux la ministre a dit qu'elle
allait ouvrir la concertation pendant 1
an pour que ce décret puisse prendre
réalité et pour que les enseignants
puissent euh s'approprier cette réforme
des collèges allez-vous donc aller à
cette négociation avec quel feuille de
route et quelle est pour chacun je
dirais votre revendication essentielle
deuxème point je vais vous demander de
faire bref madame carton sur les
questions
par affirmé et vous l'avez affirmé c'est
très juste et c'était dans la loi de
refondation de l'école que l'école
primaire devait être conforté et et et
donc mettre la priorité dessus pour les
apprentissages comme vous le
dites fondamentaux même si on pourrait
revenir sur cela donc 2uxème question
lorsqu'on a supprimé on est passé parce
que tout le monde est nostalgique des
heures d'enseignement perdu mais il y a
quelques années les à l'école primaire
il y avait 27 he de classe aujourd'hui
il y en a 24 he êtes-vous prêt et
pensez-vous qu'il faudrait remettre ces
3 heures d'enseignement qui ont disparu
et qui donc font moins d'heur lorsqu'on
lorsqu'on les comptabilise et puis enfin
euh je voudrais
je voudrais vous
demander quelle est la place pour chacun
d'entre vous du projet
d'établissement pensez-vous que
justement dans tout
établissement il quelle est sa place
avec quelle
participation et bien évidemment comment
ce projet d'établissement peut faire
équipe peut faire sens peut faire
coopération et bien et et d'où la place
là de l'Inter disciplinarité euh dernier
élément ça c'est je je le pose par
rapport on s'émeut des heures
d'accompagnement qui sont prises sur les
heures disciplinaires soi-disant ne
pensez-vous pas que lorsqu'on fait de de
l'accompagnement pour les enfants en
difficulté c'est bien évidemment
l'objectif c'est du disciplinaire de de
de l'appropriation soit de la langue
soit de soit de l'écrit soit de la
mathématique là où on a décelé quelques
failles mais c'est du disciplinaire
autrement et donc euh voilà j'aurais
voulu votre avis sur tout c question euh
voilà il reste deux orateurs ça sera 2
minutes chacun parce que sinon on va pas
pouvoir commencer notre deuxème table
ronde à l'heure donc Monsieur grosérin
Merci présidente d'avoir organisé cette
réunion merci au syndicat d'avoir
répondu présent première question je
m'interroge sur le rôle des syndicat
dans la mesure où un décret avec un beau
tour de passe-passe que Madame Cartron
vient nous faire en expliquant qu'il
était prévu depuis 2 ans moi j'ai
participé à la loi de refondation de
l'école c'est faux ce que vous dites en
tout cas ce n'est pas le cas beau tour
de passe pass donc un quel est le rôle
des syndical dans la mesure où vous
n'avez pas été entendu vous faites une
manifestation le lendemain le décress
sort je trouve ça un petit peu un petit
peu étonnant merci président d'organiser
cela deuxième question qui est en même
temps une remarque cège unique a vécu à
mon avis parce que c'est un totem pour
vous mais si la France je reviendrait
pas sur les évaluations mais on sait trs
bien que les évaluations montrent que
les plus faibles décrochent de toujours
de plus en plus donc véritablement ce
totem là est-ce qu'il mérite encore
d'exister est-ce que moi je suis pour un
socle commun de compéten et cetera une
école qui fonctionne de du primaire à la
fin de la scolarité obligatoire je
m'interroge sur les 16 ans je pense que
c'est une erreur d'aller jusqu'à 16 ans
et les enfants qui décrochent avant il
faudrait faire quelque chose ou des
passerelles ou de la
prépressionnalisation ou autres chose
trème dernière question vous comprendrez
bien ma fr frustration c'est sur les
classes bilanges on a bien compris que
cette suppression elle va favoriser le
départ parce que les établissements
privés nous l'ont bien dit ils seront
capables ils seront faire sur leurs
fonds propres ils seront capables de
financer ces formations là et ce collège
d'État ce collège d'excellence qui
pouvait à un moment donné permettre à
des enfants qui ne pouvaient pas aller
dans d'autres types d'établissement et
qui favorisaient cette mixité sociale
moi je pense que c'est une grosse erreur
ce latin pour personne c'est espagnol
pour tous je pense que c'est à un moment
donné c'est pas une refondation de
l'école c'est une destruction de l'école
qu'on met en place et je finirai par ca
parce que je pense que j'avais qu'une
minute merci Monsieur grerin Madame
Gillot madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs alors beaucoup de choses ont
été dites de manière tout à fait
intéressante et très contradictoire donc
moi je ve simplement dire que j'approuve
tout à fait j'aurais bien voulu faire la
déclaration de de Corine bouchou mais
bon je suis d'accord avec un certain
nombre de de de de de d'interventions
qui ont été faites moi je voudrais
simplement rappeler que pour qu'une loi
s'applique il faut des décrets et que
les décrets sont pris progressivement et
que chaque rapporteur de loi sonore et
se fait un une obligation de vérifier
que les décrets sortent bien moi pour
par exemple concernant la loi sur
l'enseignement supérieur la recherche je
sais qu'il y a encore deux décrets qui
ne sont pas sortis mais si un décret qui
sort et qui maintenant et qu'on dit il a
pas été concerté a pas ça ne sera pas
juste donc je crois qu'il faut qu'on
soit conscient que la loi pour
s'appliquer c'est un processus lent
progressif tout comme l'éducation est un
processus progressif et refonder l'école
a été réfléchi collectivement débattu et
adopté en 2013 et aujourd'hui on est
dans la mise en œuvre de cette belle
belle idée de refonder l'école pour
refonder la République et refonder la
République par l'école donc moi j'ai
quand même deux questions à poser parce
que le temps est
compté j'ai entendu quand même des
enseignants dire que la qualité de
l'enseignement la qualité des
apprentissage dépendrait de la quantité
de des horaires des heures euh bon là je
compte que 6h plus 1h30 de pause
méridienne les les élèves sont à l'école
pendant sont au collège pendant
7h30 euh là à l'Assemblée nationale nos
collègues députés sont en train de
discuter d'un amendement sur le burnout
qui serait reconnu comme forme comme
maladie professionnelle qu'est-ce qu'on
réserve à nos élèves en disant à nos
enfants en disant il faut toujours plus
d'heures de cours pour qu'ils apprennent
peut-être que c'est autrement qu'ils
doivent vivre à l'école qu'ils doivent
vivre au collège pour dépour à acquérir
des apprentissages pour avoir la
curiosité d'aller chercher eux-mêmes des
compétences à chercher eux-mêmes des
connaissance l'adulte n'est pas là
uniquement pour le gaver pour lui donner
comme une oix ça a été dit ou un canard
on remplit on rempl rempl puis à un
moment B le gamin il n peut plus oui je
vais à la question s'il vous mais
laissez-moi terminer 2 minutes s'il vous
plaît je crois qu'il faut qu'on là on a
en présence deux formes deux expressions
de de la manière d'éduquer les enfants
je crois qu'il y a des lectures qui
seraient bonnes à reprendre il a été
annoncé tout à l'heure un chiffre
relatif au au Marg heure professeur qui
ont
considérablement augmenté alors j'ai
compris que dans un collège de 16
classes on passe de 8h à 48 he de de
marge horaire pour organiser justement
ces missions de concertation
d'engéerie qui permettront au aux
enseignants de s'organiser est-ce que
tout le monde a bien entendu la même
chose que moi est-ce que ces 48 heur
elles existent véritablement ou est-ce
que c'est une vue de l'esprit de ceux
qui l'ont mis en évidence et que les
autres n'auraient pas vu ou
contesteraient l'existence merci Madame
Gillot donc je redonne la parole à nos
invités peut-être pour 2 minutes chacun
pour répondre et conclure en même temps
alors on va faire dans ce sens-là
allons-y oui alors tout d'abord ça fait
deux fois que j'entends un par
organisation je me permets
de deux fois que j'entends l'expression
de gavage Doig ou de canard j'aimerais
quand même signaler que les professeurs
ne gavent pas les élèves aujourd'hui en
collège et à un moment ça suffit
d'entendre des choses comme ça je trouve
ça choquant et c'est en faisant ça
excusez-moi c'est en faisant ça que la
représentation politique produit aussi
le fait qu'aujourd'hui les enseignants
sont dans des situations où ils n'en
peuvent plus et où ils expriment leur
mécontentement par tous les moyens
possibles si on présente les enseignants
de cette façon-là il ne faut pas
s'étonner qu'ensuite il vous le renvoie
dans la
figure maintenant que j'ai dit cela la
le projet de collège modulaire dont nous
avons parlé il est disponible sur notre
site on peut l'envoyer à qui veut
effectivement il nous semble beaucoup
plus efficace à destination notamment
des élèves les plus en difficulté pour
qu'ils appellent ce que l'on peut tout à
fait nommer un sole commun et de ce
point de vue-là il nous semble que c'est
un objectif à atteindre et que l'on
n'atteindra pas avec la définition
actuelle du SO le commun qui demande aux
élèves à peu près 200 compétences
différentes qui sont tout à fait
inaccessibles probablement même par
l'ensemble des personnes qui sont dans
cette salle sur la dernière chose sur
les heures en plus là cette marge
horaire d'une part non elle ne doit elle
ne peut pas servir à détend de
concertation entre professeurs ce n'est
pas prévu dans le texte d'autre part
cette marge horaire elle a été fabriquée
notamment en ponctionnant sur ce que
l'on a vu la suppression des classes
européennes des bilanges et cetera c'est
comme ça he qu'on la fabrique en grande
partie cette marche horaire et je tiens
à ajouter que cette marge horaire elle
va créer des discriminations entre les
collèges suivant leur taille
c'est-à-dire que des collèges de petite
taille s'ils veulent mettre en place du
latin avec un horaire moindre que celui
qui est actuellement ils vont
proportionnellement devoir prendre
davantage sur leur marge horaire et un
collège de petite taille qui aujourd'hui
proposait une bilangue 1 € du latin et
une découverte professionnelle ce qui
arrive finalement assez fréquemment la
marge horaire finalement ne compense pas
la les suppressions qui sont faites
alors que sur un collège de grande
taille ce ne sera pas la même chose et
le même calcul donc à l'arrivée cette
réforme là de toute façon et cette
interdisciplinarité dont on n pas arrêté
de parler si on l'applique comme ça d'en
haut en 2016 les professeurs finiront
par faire ce qui s'est passé avec les
itinéraires de découverte c'est-à-dire
qu'ils arrêteront de le faire parce que
ça ne fonctionnera pas merci Monsieur
marcillou
oui sur les façon dont cette dont s'est
faite cette ce enfin cette négociation
qui n'a pas eu lieu alors effectivement
il y a une loi de refondation simplement
comme ça a été dit tout à l'heure la loi
de refondation ne prévoyait absolument
pas la structuration du collège il y
avait des il y avait effectivement des
éléments de réflexion sur le socle alors
mon organisation syndicale était contre
la lo refondation et si est opposé pas
notamment parce qu'on on est en
désaccord sur la notion de socle commun
et compéten mais par ailleurs il à aucun
moment n'a été décrit dans cette loi la
façon dont on allait faire fonctionner
le collège à aucun moment on a parlé de
l'autonomie des établissements dans
cette loi d'ailleurs le on attendait
même un bilan de la réforme des lycées
qui a mis en place cette même autonomie
qu'on est en train de généraliser au
collège le bilan on ne l'a toujours pas
et bizarrement maintenant on comprend
pourquoi puisqu'on a vu le bilan en fait
avec ce décret donc oui sur la
structuration de ce du collège on a eu
le décret on a eu trois journées de
trois soirées de discussion enfin
soirées de de de deux ou trois réunions
de 3h donc non pour nous c'était
totalement insuffisant on avait des
choses à proposer moi j'entends gavage
et cetera alors c'est vrai que il faut
peut-être penser que les collègues ont
des élèves en phase de qui se et que ils
ils pensent au bien de leurs élèves et
qu'ils évitent de faire du gavage c'est
une façon de de regarder la profession
qui est quand même
totalement c'est assez scandaleux je
pense que les les les les collègues
n'aimeraient pas entendre ça parce que
c'est ils se battent pour faire réussir
leurs élèves ils n'y arrivent pas et là
on est d'accord que le collège il y a un
vrai problème et il faut refonder mais
de là à les traités de gaveur c'est un
petit peu grossier donc non mais non
mais en même temps ne car bien qu'on ne
caricature pas qu'on ne caricature pas
les positions syndical c'est pas parce
qu'on estime que le collège tel qu'il
est ne fonctionne pas bien ce n'est pas
parce qu'on estime que par exemple la
terdisciplinearité sont des pistes que
effectivement on peut aussi espérer que
les enfants s'amusent en collège je vous
rassure on espère tout au bout d'un
moment c'est on peut quand même
réfléchir à à se dire que on peut ne pas
être d'accord sur le l'objectif de cette
réforme tout en étant en désaccord avec
cette notion de gavage et cetera donc ne
caricaturez pas les positions syndicales
non plus je vais donc pour la répondre
je conclu pour la répondre à la question
sur la la refondation et sur le sur les
la proposition de la ministre de
négocier alors moi j'ai du mal à
comprendre nous à notre organisation
syndicale on est opposé avec le décret
en tel qu'il est donc il or de question
d' négocié l'application décret qui
serait déjà lui-même l'application d'une
loi de refondation après j'ai du mal à
comprendre puisque j'entends que là elle
propose même une discussion longue d'un
an on nous avait dit pourtant que ce
décret devait sortir très vite pour
préparer en amont la rentrée 2016 donc
j'ai du mal à
comprendre le rythme de des discussions
que veut imposer la ministre en tout cas
la réponse est pour mon organisation
syndicale non nous n'irons
pas Madame
relay non mais je je je crois qu'il y a
beaucoup de choses ont été ont été dites
encore une fois sur des objectifs qui
étaient des objectifs nobles tendre
tendre vers plus d'égalité entre les
élèves entre les établissements ça
supposait de prendre le temps de poser
sur la table toute une série de sujets
he j'en ai évoqué la carte scolaire les
carartte des option et cetera de
regarder comment on metettait en place
une interdisciplinarité qui soit portée
par les personnels et euh qui donc
suppose un certain nombre de conditions
progressivité formation des enseignants
cointervention tout ça n'est pas n'est
pas prévu encore une fois le décret euh
pouvait attendre alors c'est un décret
cadre mais il éta accompagné en plus
d'un arrêté qu'il a pour le coup est
déjà le mode opératoire de la réforme
donc je vois pas très bien maintenant
quelle marge de manœuvre il reste au
personnel que nous
représentons réponse je donne la parole
à Monsieur sève maintenant qui va
essayer d'être concis mais c'est
difficile beaucoup de questions ont été
posées alors euh premièrement euh il a
été évoqué le plusieurs fois d'ailleurs
mais une question a été posée sur en
quelque sorte ce qu'on appelle le
collège modulaire ou ce que d'autres
appellent le collège modulaire je
voudrais juste si le collège modulaire
si la modularité que je défends par
ailleurs pour le lycée hein où on a des
parcours effectivement au lycée les les
parcours sont explicitement distincts
mais si dans l'école obligatoire si au
niveau collège on défend la modularité
comme un modèle de réussite pourquoi ne
l'appliquons-nous pas au primairire
pourquoi est-ce que quand on a créé
quand à la fin à la 3e république
l'école publique l'école primaire a été
instittué pourquoi n'-elle pas été
instituée sur la base de cette
modularité que vous revendiquez pour le
collège nous pour pour nous c'est clair
à la CFDT enseignement obligatoire veut
bien dire enseignement obligatoire et
objectif commun pour tous veut bien dire
même type d'enseignement c'est bien au
niveau local encore une fois des
pratiques pédagogiques que la
distinction doit se faire il y a deux
modèles hein deux modèles différents il
faut les assumer mais voilà je dirais ma
première réponse sur cette histoire de
cette proposition de modularité pourquoi
ne l'appliquons-nous pas à l'école si
elle est si si efficace 2è élément
repéré sur les les et encore une fois ce
qu'on appelait tout à l'heure les les
les compétences fondamentales bon je vis
juste faire remarquer que apparemment
nous maîtrisons tous ici le lire écrire
compé j'en suis certain mais
manifestement nous lisons pas tous la
loi de la même façon et nous ne nous ne
comptons pas tous de la même façon les
les horaires les heures consacrées à à
la au dédoublement par exemple sans
parler des chiffres de grevistes ou de
manifestants donc tout ça pour dire que
au-delà de ces il faut aller plus loin
hein ces compétences ne sont jamais
simples jamais fondamentales il faut
travailler il faut approfondir c'est
bien tout le travail encore une fois qui
est fait mais ne simplifions pas à
l'excès les compétences que l'on vise
alors sur la concertationoup d'autres
questions oui je fais très court mais
j'essaie aussi de répondre un tout petit
peu quand même sinon l'exercice sera
vraiment formel sur la quantité et
qualité effectivement il faut se poser
la question de la qualité de
l'enseignement euh le gavage c'est un
terme que moi j'entends enfin que j'ai
entendu prononcer par mes collègues et
qui désigent essentiellement les
programmes les programmes et la façon
dont on comptabilise dont on réduit
l'enseignement à une accumulation
d'heures mais encore une fois c'est un
terme de professeur hein donc bon soyons
clair ne défendons pas un système tel
qu'il existe au nom d'une défense de de
la de au nom de la défense des collègues
sur la concertation dernière chose je
rappelle que ce décret alors il sort pas
de n'importe où il sort du Conseil
supérieur de l'éducation où il a reçu un
avis donc il est pour nous il est temps
effectivement de passer à la à la non
pas une phase de discussion encore sur
le décret et l'arrêter mais sur ce qui
se passe après c'est là qu'il y a besoin
de concertation oui nous irons à la
concertation pour justement euh veiller
à ce que à ce que la phase de discussion
sur l'application soit fructueuse et
soit et soit soit réelle mais je
rappelle et j'insiste beaucoup c'est pas
au niveau national que l'essentiel de la
discussion doit se faire maintenant
c'est bien dans les collèges au sein des
équipes éducatives que l'essentiel de la
discussion doit se faire et on doit pas
en retardant les décisions nationales
confisquer ce temps de discussion locale
et en privé les collègues voilà ce que
je dire j'ai sûement oublié quelques
éléments mais vous m'en excuserez merci
beaucoup madame
creè euh sur la sur ce qui figurait dans
la loi de refondation il y figurait le
les enseignements de Tron commun et les
enseignements complémentaires et
l'autonomie hein les trois éléments
étaient inscrits dans la loi de
refondation ce qui n'était pas expliqué
c'était comment on articulait le Tron
commun et les enseignements
complémentaires le choix qui a été fait
d'inclure les enseignements
complémentaires dans les horair
disciplinairees est un choix très
important à notre avis parce que il
légitime c'est enseignements
complémentaires en les inscrivant dans
ce qui fait la professionnalité et
l'identité professionnelle des
enseignants leurs horaires
disciplinaires quand un enseignement ou
un dispositif est placé en dehors des
horaires disciplinaires on voit ce qu'il
en advient c'était le cas des IDD qui
ont été très vite ou dans certains dans
certains établissements en tout cas
transformé en moyen complémentaires pour
mettre en place des dispositifs autres
ou autres autres cas de figure supprimé
par une majorité différente qui jugait
que les travaux interdisciplinaires
n'étaient pas intéressants ça été par
exemple le cas des TPE au moins pour une
année hein puisqu'ils étaient sur 2 ans
au lycée ils ne sont devenus plus que
obligatoires sur une seule année dans la
mesure où c'était trop facile de quelque
part de les récupérer puisqu'ils
n'étaient pas inscrits dans les
disciplines donc pour nous c'est vrai
nous l'avons nous avons mené ce combat
de l'inscription dans les horaires
disciplinaires de ces de ces
enseignements complémentaires pour
éviter qu'il soit si très facilement
récupérable lors d'un changement de
majorité nous participerons bien sûr à
la concertation sur la
circulaire parce que nous
souhaitons que cette circulaire puisse
rendre le changement concrets auprès de
nos
collègues tout en leur laissant les
marges de choix et d'autonomie dont ils
ont besoin pour répondre aux besoins de
leurs élèves nous souhaitons que cette
autonomie ne soit pas une autonomie à
tout craint nous avons depuis le début
milité pour cadrer cette autonomie de
manière à assurer l'équité de traitement
entre les élèves et entre les
enseignants et nous continuerons
effectivement à porter quelques règles
de essentiel pour cadrer cette autonomie
de manière à assurer donc cette équité
quant le dernier point sur lequel je
voudrais revenir c'est sur les moyens
complémentaires effectivement ils sont
liés à la taille de l'établissement mais
ça n'est pas nouveau en gén on a plus de
moyens quand on a plus d'élèves euh dans
un dans un collège moyen on aura grosso
modo un demi Poe en plus un demi- Poe en
plus pour faire fonctionner le collège
la dotation de base hein c'est celle
dont on parle là là c'est la dotation de
base mais cette dotation elle est
modulée dans les académies vous le savez
bien les recteurs donnent des moyens
complémentaires en fonction d'une
certaine typologie des établissements le
rural isolé par exemple a droit à des
moyens supplémentaires parce qu'il a des
taux h sur beaucoup plus important le et
d'autres et d'autres critères sont pris
en compte donc les moyens ne seront pas
réduits à ceux qui sont pour l'instant
affichés dans la dotation de base faire
le dire le contraire et il me semble
vouloir
induire vouloir conduire nos collègues à
mal comprendre le sens de la réforme on
sait qu'il y a des postes créés il n'est
pas question de récupérer des moyens sur
euh les euh la qualité des enseignements
dans le cadre de cette réforme bien au
contraire oui madame cè donc je vais
intervenir pour le SNF OLC alors je
voudrais qu'on fasse attention à la
façon dont on parle des enseignants et
je pense qu'il faut vraiment prendre
conscience que les enseignants sont
capables par eux-mêmes de comprendre la
réforme euh moi j'en ai discuté avec mes
collègues de la réforme à partir d'un
document qui était la grille horaire que
proposait le ministère lors de la
première réunion euh et les collègues
ont réagi très vivement à cette grille
horaire je pense que ça se passe
d'explication quand il faut bien
expliquer une réforme aux enseignants
pour qu'ils la comprennent il y a déjà
peut-être un problème par ailleurs je
voudrais revenir sur les 60000 postes
les 60000 postes créés alors il devrait
se traduire ces 60000 postes par la
création de classe et donc la baisse des
effectifs dans les classes
or or c'est pas le cas or les effectifs
ne cessent d'augmenter dans les classes
euh je je finis là-dessus on parle de on
parle de s'éclater au au au travail hein
euh on parle de de sénateurs qui qui
enfin vous vous êtes certains vous
parlez de votre expérience vous avez
rencontrer des professeurs vous êtes
allé dans les classes et cetera moi
j'enseigne donc je vois très bien ce qui
se passe également en plus j'ai enseigné
dans différents établissements depuis
que j'ai commencé et ce qu'on constate
et ce qu'on constate clairement c'est
qu'on ne peut pas s'éclater les élèves
ne peuvent pas s'éclater que ce soit les
élèves qui soi faible ou que ce soit les
élèves qui soient forts entre guillemets
he d'accord que ce soient les élèves qui
a des difficultés ou ceux qui sont en
avance sur les autres ils ne peuvent
s'éclater quand ils sont à à 30 à 30
dans les classes c'est pas possible
voilà donc je pense que de ce point de
vue-là la réforme ne fait qu'aggraver
les choses et c'est pour c'est pourquoi
nous demandons son
abrogation bien est-ce que c'est le mot
de la fin bien non non non non non non
parce que nous non non je vais non non
je vais conclure parce que je demande un
dro de réponse
parés s'il vous plît mes propos ont été
mais je n'ai pas dit que les professeurs
étaient j'ai une comparaison entre la
qualité d'enseignement et la quantité
d'heur et j'ai repris malencontreusement
un mot que je vous demande de retirer et
je présente mes excuses à ceux qui sont
été indignés par mes propos toute façon
madame Gillot ce que je voulais dire de
toute façon en notre nom à tous
représente non non mais attendez au nom
à nos invités d'abord que je remercie
vraiment d'avoir consacré du temps je
pense que vous auriez aimé peut-être
avoir plus de temps encore pour pouvoir
vous exprimer et nous aussi plus de
temps pour vous poser des questions et
de et dialoguer ce n'est que partie
remise on entame ainsi un dialogue c'est
leur dire à quel point le métier de
l'enseignant au nom des membres de la
commission c'est un métier que nous
respectons
éminemment vous êtes les piliers de de
notre République on compte sur vous nous
sommes nombreux d'ailleurs à être
enseignants dans cette commission donc
nous partageons un certain nombre de vos
préoccupations et de de vos réflexions
sachez-le je voulais juste faire une
toute petite précision parce qu'on s'est
dit est-ce que la loi du sur le collège
la réforme du collège a été annoncée
dans dans la loi j'ai pris la peine
d'aller regarder dans le texte cette
réforme du du
collège le rapport annexé repenser le
collège unique mais pas dans la loi en
tant que telle c'est vrai que ça pose la
question du statut des rapports annexés
dans les les textes de loi je fais juste
cette cette remarque de façon neutre
elle est bien annoncée dans le rapport
annexé voilà pour cette audition sur le
thème de la réforme du collège pendant
plus d'une heure vous avez pu entendre
les représentants des syndicats
d'enseignants répondre aux questions des
sénateurs de la commission de la culture
du Sénat une réforme je vous le rappelle
qui crée la polémique une semaine jour
pour jour après la publication au
Journal officiel du décret d'application
de cette fameuse réforme les par
parlementaire se plaignent en nombre
d'avoir été privé de débat sur ce thème
on retourne tout de suite en audition
pour écouter cette fois-ci les
représentants des associations de
parents d'élèves toujours devant la
commission de la culture du
Sénat donc nous avons représentons de la
la PEP Madame Valérie Marti de l'appel
monsieur
hervéjean ainsi que Madame CVI Fromentel
qui représente la FCPE je vais me
dispenser de discours liminires pour mes
collègues parce que nous sommes très
contraints dans notre emploi du temps ce
matin on a un peu débordé veuillez nous
excuser aussi de vous avoir fait
attendre donc je vais vous donner
immédiatement la parole à à chacun
d'entre vous pour 5 minutes pour
exprimer votre point de vue sur cette
réforme du collège annoncé donc par
décret qui fait débat aujourd'hui nous
voulons vous entendre parce que nous
avons besoin que vous éclairiez notre
réflexion sur le sujet alors je commence
par Madame Valérie
pour la PEP nous nous sommes abstenus au
Conseil supérieur des des programmes
Conseil supérieur de l'éducation parce
que nous étions pas complètement
convaincus par la réforme du collège ça
fait 35 ans qu'on parle de réformer le
collège les parents observent les
difficultés des élèves au sein de ces
des des établissements il y a donc la
problématique pour les parents de la pb
sont comment on peut gérer la diversité
et les besoins divers des élèves comment
aider au mieux les les élèves qui ont
des lacunes qui ont des difficultés et
comment euh aider ceux qui vont très
très vite et qui qui n'ont pas de
difficultés particulière alors sur cette
réforme nous avons accueilli
favorablement la demande que nous avions
faite qui est que l'enseignement de la
langue vivante commence en 5e c'est
naturel et normal nous avons aussi
accueilli favorablement le fait que il y
ait des enseignements euh pratique
interdisciplinaire c'est-à-dire que que
les élèves puissent à travers des
projets travailler déjà en groupe et
mieux comprendre peut-être des
disciplines en tout cas travailler
autrement et ça c'est important pour les
parents
d'élèves les parents euh par rapport à
nos consultations les parents au niveau
de la réforme du collège était favorable
au fait que on puiss puisse peut-être
diminuer les heures disciplinaires afin
de d'offrir aux élèves des heures
d'accompagnement c'est-àdire permettre
aux élèves d'être accompagnés dans leur
apprentissage dans la méthodologie et
ainsi faire autre chose que de
l'enseignement des savoirs et des
compétences donc l'aide personnalisée
qui est proposé au niveau de la réforme
du collège nous semble aller aussi dans
le bon sens
ensuite sur l'enseignement des langues
nous aurions souhaité que il y ait une
réflexion qu' soit menée plus sur la
manière dont on enseigne les langues
vivantes en France et particulièrement
au collège et puis ensuite au lycée euh
les parents d'élèves ont été comment
dire non pas ne sont pas d'accord avec
la suppression des sections européennes
non pas que ça soit des sections je
dirais euh euh comme ça a été dit
souvent euh élitiste des sections qui
regroupent des bons élèves mais ce sont
des une manière différentes d'enseigner
les langues vivantes et ce qui est
important ce qu'on aurait aimé c'est que
euh on réforme enfin qu'on qu'on parte à
partir de ce qui était euh fait dans les
sections européennes et particulièrement
ce qui est fait dans les sections
européennes du lycée pour permettre euh
de de réformer d'offrir un enseignement
des langues euh vivantes comme euh comme
ça peut se faire au dans les sections
européennes c'est-à-dire qu'on enseigne
par exemple comme ça se fait l'éducation
physique en anglais par exemple ou
d'autres matières en anglais
c'est-à-dire que la langue vivante soit
vraiment parlé et soit euh à un moment
donné dans
l'enseignement vu comme ça par les
élèves donc réformer plutôt les les
l'enseignement des langues vivantes et
euh revoir un petit peu cette idée de
section de section européenne voilà je
crois que j'ai fait le tour très bien
nous avons l'occasion de revenir vers à
vous pour sans doute des questions je
donne donc la parole à Monsieur
hervéjean pour l'appel allez-y madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs je
voudrais tout d'abord rappeler que je
m'exprime ici au nom de l'appel donc
l'association des parents d'élèves de
l'enseignement libre association
àolitique et non confessionnel qui
regroupe 880000 familles ayant fait le
choix de l'enseignement catholique pour
l'un ou l'autre de leurs enfants avant
d'exposer notre position sur cette
réforme que nous avons soutenu au CSE je
voudrais rappeler les raisons qui nous
font penser qu'une réforme profonde de
notre système scolaire est nécessaire du
primaire bien sûr mais aussi du
secondaire en particulier du collège
comment vous nousons nous satisfaire
d'une situation où les performances de
notre système scolaire ne cessent de de
se dégrader en tout cas c'est ce que
montrent les études PISA depuis 12 ans
comment accepter que 150000 élèves
sortent du système scolaire sans
qualification et comment accepter que
notre système soit de plus en plus plus
injuste puisque les les enfants fant il
lieu de issu de milieu défavorisés ont
beaucoup moins de chance que ceux issus
de milieu plus favorisés donc pour ces
trois principales raisons nous pensons
que cette réforme qu'une réforme du
collège est nécessaire mais qu'une
réforme non seulement est nécessaire
mais qu'il est urgent de faire ces
réformes et nous formulons le vœux que
pour une fois nous réussissions à enfin
que que cette réforme aboutisse et que
on soit pas comme bien souvent à dire
qu'une réforme c'est bien mais que ce
n'est pas la bonne réforme et depuis 30
ans c'est c'est souvent le cas
c'est-à-dire qu'on pense que c'est à
chaque fois on les réformes
n'aboutissent pas parce que on dit que
ce n'est pas la bonne réforme ça fait
plusieurs années que l'appel se
préoccupe de cette réflexion sur le
collège un sondage que nous avons miné
en en février 2011 montrait que pour
près de la moitié des parents d'élèves
45 % exactement le collège fonctionnait
mal qu'il ne favorisait pas les qualités
des chance et qu'il permettait surtout
une sélection des meilleurs bref nous
avons fait depuis longtemps le constat
du que ce collège tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui ne fonctionne pas bien et
qui peinene à remplir ses missions
c'est-à-dire permettre à tous les élèves
d'une classe d'âge d'acquérir les
savoirs et les compétences nécessaires
pour se construire construire leur vie
d'adulte et s'insérer dans la société
c'est ainsi quand le 5 avril 2011 ici
même au au Sénat nous organisions un
petit déjeuner débat sur le thème
inventons le collège de demain et parmi
les propositions que nous faisions à
l'époque figurait notamment le
renforcement de l'autonomie des
établissements la refondte des
programmes un meilleur accompagnement
des élèves du CM2 à la 6e la
suprogression progressive du
redoublement et l'amélioration de les de
l'évaluation des élèves donc vous
comprendrez bien que c'est assez logique
que partant de cette réflexion que nous
avons mené depuis plusieurs années avec
ce type de proposition et bien nous
allons nous soutenons des propositions
qui vont dans ce sens-là dans le dans le
cadre de cette réforme alors tout
particulièrement il y a trois points qui
nous semblent intéressants le premier
étant l'autonomie des établissements
euh dans le cadre de ces 20 %
l'équivalent de 20 % des temps
d'enseignement nous pensons que c'est
très important effectivement de donner
aux équipes
éducatives aux enseignants aux chefs
d'établissement la possibilité de mieux
adapter leurs proposition à la diversité
des élèves qu' sont qui qu'ils
accueillent euh nous pensons que le le
collège pour tous ne doit pas être un
collège uniforme pour tous il faut
développer un un collège où chacun
pourra développer ses capacités en
fonction de sa forme d'intelligence un
collège qui permette de parvenir au
meilleur à chacun de parvenir au
meilleur de lui-même chacun chacun
pourra avoir un parcours de réussite et
c'est donc pour nous un des éléments
clés de la réforme que nous soutenons le
deuxième point c'est la mise en place
des enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaires cela nous paraît
effectivement quelque chose qui va dans
la bonne direction le pouvoir allier à
la fois des enseignements théoriques et
des enseignements pratiques l'on sait
que là aussi un certain nombre d'élèves
peine avec une approche uniquement
théorique que la question du sens des
apprentissages est un élément important
de motivation et de compréhension et
d'implication donc des des élèves et il
nous semble que cette que cette
proposition permettrait d'améliorer les
choses et d'aller donc dans cette dans
cette direction là et puis c'est aussi
une façon de développer d'aider les
jeunes à développer la leur créativité
leur leur aisence leur capacité à
s'exprimer leur capacité à mener un
projet leur capacité à entreprendre
voilà donc cette cette proposition nous
semble intéressante et puis la troisième
proposition qui nous semble également et
qui qui faisait là aussi partie de nos
réflexion c'est tout ce qui contribue à
à améliorer le passage de du CM2 à la 6e
donc cet accompagnement personnalisé
qu'on va dire un peu renforcé nous
paraît important pour permettre à des
jeunes particulièrement sur ceux qui
sont peut-être le moins les moins en
confiance de mieux comprendre ce qu'on
attend d'eux de mieux comprendre ce
qui'est le collège de savoir comment
mieux apprendre bref de repartir avec de
bonnes bases plutôt que d'arriver déjà
un peu fragilisé au départ du de ce
collège alors il y a un point sur lequel
nous sommes euh disons plus réservés qui
est la question des langues vivantes
alors tout en soutenant le principe du
du démarrage de la 2è langue en 5e euh
qui nous paraît effectivement une idée
intéressante en revanche nous regrettons
la la la suppression des classes
bilangues et des classes européennes euh
et il nous semble que là c'est plutôt
plutôt une erreur par parce que c'est
c'est ce dispositif avait avait apporté
nous semble-t-il en tout cas beaucoup de
points positifs et globalement c'était
plutôt quelque chose de qui qui qui
était perçu comme une positivement par
les parents voilà pour terminer
simplement le point d'attention enfin
mais je pense qu'évidemment tout vous en
estes tous persuadés je crois que ce qui
le point important c'est évidemment va
être la mise en œuvre de la réforme et
bien entendu il faut que les enseignants
les chefs d'Ét issement toute la
communauté éducative se sent concerné
par cette réforme cela se l'approprie et
c'est ce qui fera ou pas le succès de la
réforme en tout cas nous association de
parents d'élèves nous sommes prêts à
prendre notre place pour bah contribuer
à la mise en avant bien on vous remerci
euh madame Sylvie fromontel vous êtes
secrétaire générale de la FCPE vous avez
la
parole bon bonjour à tous
euh donc je ferai un exposé en trois
points donc déjà ce que nous qu'est-ce
que en fait ce qui nous paraît
intéressant dans la réforme et un deuxè
point sur ce qui ce qui est un peu plus
négative et une troisème partie sur
qu'est-ce qui quells sont les conditions
à mettre en œuvre pour pouvoir y
arriver donc pour nous les les les
principales avancé pour la FCPE c'est
d'abord des nouvelles pratiques
pédagogiques le développement de
l'interdisciplinarité l'accompagnement
spécialisé pour tous le renforcement des
langues
vivantes et puis il y a la question
aussi des rythmes au collège pour en
particulier avec 0 90 minutes de pause
méridienne pour la création aussi
d'un d'un d'un conseil de vie
collégienne qui pour en fait nous paraît
important pour justement pour que les
pour les que les collégiens
puissent puissent pouvoir pratiquer la
la démocratie dans le leur propres
établissement et s'investir dans dans la
vie de leur établissement autre point
qui nous nous paraît important et que
qu'on demandait aussi depuis quelques
années c'était davantage d'autonomie des
établissements et un vrai travail en un
vrai travail en équipe au sein des
établissements où tous les personnes
tout tous les personnels puissent être
associés à l'organisation du du des
collèges donc nous ce qu'on attend
princip principalement pour pour la
suite c'est c'est la question des
nouveaux programmes nous enfin la
réforme du collège est complètement lié
pour nous à au nouveaux programmes et
que c'est ces programmes soient beaucoup
plus cohérents qu'ils ne sont
actuellement il y a la question
d'évaluation
qui pour permettre en particulier de
valoriser les progrès et motiver les
élèves et non pas que ce soit quelque
chose
négatif nous ce qui nous paraî aussi
important à renforcer c'est la question
la continuité écolecollège qui qui où il
y a un vrai travail de partenariat avec
les parents qui doient aussi se mettre
en place et puis l'autre enjeu en fait
de cette réforme ça devait ça devait ça
devrait être pardon la question de
l'implication des parents dans la vie
des établissements pour nous c'est
vraiment quelque chose un point
important parce qu'on le sait tous c'est
que plus les les parents sont impliqués
dans la scolarité de leurs enfants mieux
euh plus les enfants peuvent
réussir donc et sur la question des
rythmes pour nous ça nous paraît
important aussi de que ce soit un temps
aussi un temps éducatif et pas un temps
pour que les élèves se retrouvent aussi
un peu tout seul et autre point aussi
pour nous qui nous paraît aussi
important à améliorer c'est le
calendrier annuel euh des des rythmes en
particul
pour pour des
collégiens alors pour nous en fait tout
ça ne peut ne pourra pas fonctionner si
il y a pas suffisamment de réel enfin
s'il y a pas suffisamment de postes mis
en mis en place pour cette
réforme et c'est vrai que dans nos
établissements on a la question des
remplacements des remplaçants quand les
enseignants peuvent être absents et ça
c'est un vrai problème qui on fait aussi
qui qui est aussi à résoudre
c'est-à-dire qu'il est suffisamment de
remplaçant dans les collèges pour
assurer ça mais il y a pas que cette
question moyen d'enseignants il y a
aussi tout un toute une série de
d'autres personnels qui doivent être
aussi renforcés je pense en particulier
au médecins scolaires aux assistants
d'éducation voire au
Copsi pour nous aussi ce qui doit être
aussi amélioré dans les établissements
c'est la question de la mixité sociale
et une chose capitale c'est que cette
réforme ne pourra pas réussir
tant que il y aura pas de formation
continue suffisante pour les enseignants
et et là c'est un vrai problème je pense
qu'il y a un vrai travail de de faire
d'accompagnement des des enseignants sur
cette réforme mais aussi un travail
d'accompagnement pour les parents il y a
un certain nombre de choses qui doivent
être expliquées aux parents et puis
euh il y a il y a un vrai travail à
faire dans chaque établissement un
travail de terrain dans pour pour des
formations pour vraiment
et donner une capacité d'innovation plus
importante que ce qu'il y a
actuellement bien je je vous remercie
mes chers collègues nous avons une
petite trentaine de de de minutes
puisque nous devons installer notre
mission d'information à 1215 je vous
propose une prise de parole par groupe 5
minutes par groupe cibler sur des
questions bien précises pour nous aider
à continuer à progresser notre réflexion
en commençant peut-être par Madame ferra
qui est par ailleurs rapporteur pour
l'enseignement agricole qui représente
oui merci madame la Présidente notre
rapporteur éducation nationale
Jean-Claude Carles est empêché pour un
court moment et a souhaité que je puisse
vous soumettre ses questions la première
de celle-ci concerne le principe de la
réforme et l'apprentissage des
fondamentaux si à l'issue de la
scolarité au collège 20 % environ des
élèves ne maîtrisent pas les compétences
de base en français et 20 % d'élèves ont
une maîtrise insuffisante des
mathématiques il ne faut pas oublier
qu'une proportion comparable voire
supérieure d'élèv présente des lacunes
grave dans les apprentissages
fondamentaux à leur entrée au collège
ainsi notre collège ne parvient pas à
résorber les difficultés des élèves à
qui l'école primaire n'a pu inculquer
les acquis fondamentaux or on sait
aujourd'hui que le destin scolaire des
élèves est cé très tôt dès la fin du
cycle 2 plutôt que d'uniformiser par le
bas les apprentissages au collège
notamment en détruisant les filières des
excellence en supprimant les options de
langue ancienne ou en imposant une
seconde langue vivante dès la classe de
5e dont l'inefficacité a été prouvée à
l'occasion de son expérimentation ne
faudrait-il pas plutôt concentrer les
efforts sur l'école élémentaire afin que
les que tous les élèves à l'issue de
celle-ci maîtrisent pleinement les
savoirs fondamentaux le point suivant
concerne la réduction du nombre d'heur
consacré aux enseignements
disciplinaires notre rapporteur est
particulièrement préoccupé par un des
grands principes de cette réforme
réduire le temps d'enseignement
disciplinaire au profit de
l'accompagnement personnalisé et des
enseignement pratique interdisciplinaire
si en apparence le volume global horaire
deort peu ou prou identique 20 % de ce
temps sera consacré à l'accompagnement
personnalisé et au projets
interdisciplinaire nous ne sommes pas
opposés à l'accompagnement personnalisé
et au projet mais nous pensons que ceci
doit venir en complément des
enseignements et non s'y substituer
quelle est votre position mesdames
messieurs à ce sujet ne faudrait-il pas
plutôt consacrer davantage de temps aux
apprentissages fondamentaux notamment au
français dont le volume horaire est en
diminution constante depuis 40 ans le
point suivant concerne la pertinence des
enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaires et cette question
vous l'avez compris est complémentaire
de la précédente quelle est la
pertinence d'introduire ces
enseignements pratiques au collège ces
dernières rappelle furieusement les
itinéraires de découverte au collège ou
les Travaux Pratiques Encadrés au lycée
qui n'ont pas connu un Fran succès leur
intérêt n'est-il pas conditionné par la
maîtrise des acquis et par une solide
culture générale chose rare en classe de
5e et ne risque-t-il pas justement de ne
bénéficier qu'aux bons élèves un point
qui concerne l'orientation et dans ce
domaine la réforme prévoit la
suppression des options de découverte
professionnelle au profit du parcours
individuel d'information d'orientation
et de découverte du monde économique et
du professionnel et ce parcours ne
bénéficie d'aucune dotation horaire
spécifique et devra donc être organisé
sur du temps disciplinaire tout semble
fait pour éloigner davantage les élèves
de la voie professionnelle qui derrière
les beau discours semble plus que jamais
dévalorisés par l'Éducation nationale et
enfin quel regard portez-vous sur les
nouveaux projets de programme vous
paraissent-il satisfaisant merci Madame
et madame la Présidente est-ce que vous
me permettez
de croyz que vous aviez terminé de de de
poser mes questions personnelles en tant
que rapporteur du budget de
l'enseignement agricole préférez-vous
que je prenne la parole plus tard
allez-y
allez-y je je je je fais suite
évidemment au propos de de mon collègue
et
euh j'aurais plutôt un témoignage et
deux
questions certaines dispositions qui
sont introduites par le décret et
l'arrêté sont déjà mis en œuvre dans
l'enseignement agricole et à l'instar de
de l'accompagnement personnalis
ou de l'autonomie pédagogique cependant
celle-ci s'y accompagne d'une vraie
autonomie de gestion au service d'un
véritable projet ne pourrait-on pas s'en
inspirer davantage et et je reprends les
propos de notre collègue tout à l'heure
et ça marche je crois qu'il est bien de
de le dire et le répéter chers collègues
l'orientation je n'y reviens pas je
viens de de de vous rapporter les propos
de mon collègue évidemment ils sont les
mêmes ils sont évidemment les grands
absents de de cette réforme euh et une
inquiétude faudra-t-il donc ponctionner
les disciplines pour organiser le le
parcours concernant l'orientation et
plus généralement cette réforme
s'inscrit dans la continuité d'une
logique qui est à l'œuvre au sein de
l'éducation nationale et que je dénonce
depuis nombre d'années depuis plus d'une
décennie maintenant euh celle-ci
considère qu'il convient de retarder le
plus tard possible l'orientation et d'en
orienter le plus grand nombre possible
vers les filières générales souvent sans
considération de leur niveau scolaire et
de leurs aspirations ceci relève d'une
vision dépassée d'une hiérarchie des
savoirs et des intelligences qui demeure
particulièrement prignante aujourd'hui
et d'ailleurs nous avons entendu tout à
l'heure que l'orientation se faisait en
lycée professionnel pardonnez-moi mes
chers collègues mais je crois que
lorsqu'on est en lycée professionnel il
est un peu tard pour avoir une
orientation
intelligente merci Monsieur manier
monsieur grin et Madame bouchou merci
Madame présidente bien moi j'ai entendu
avec beaucoup d'intérêt les propos de
nos trois représentants des associations
de parents d'élèves qui ont tous des
propos pu qui vont plutôt dans le sens
positif par rapport à la réforme qui est
proposée ça ne m'étonne pas parce que il
y a un vrai partenariat autour de
l'école de l'école et du collège
aujourd'hui avec les parents d'élèves
les personnels de l'Éducation nationale
les collectivité les parents d'élèves
sont les trois piliers de la
construction de l'école et et du
moi j'ai simplement un petit regret que
que je dis devant eux mais c'est que
trop souvent dans nos communes dans nos
département l'organisation des parents
d'élèves échappe aux grandes
organisations et on a souvent des
groupes qui se disent indépendants
autonomes et qui oublient tout
simplement qu'il y a des gens qui font
de la recherche dans des grandes
fédérations comme les leurs et qui ne
veulent pas s'y affilier de peur de
soi-disant politiser et cetera moi à
chaque fois que je peux je leur dis
qu'il y a effectivement des structures
qui peuvent leur venir en aide parce que
on est parent d'élèves mais on a besoin
aussi d'avoir des éléments parfois on
n'est pas parce que on découvre d'un
seul coup ce qui se passe à l'école on a
aussi besoin d'avoir au niveau national
au niveau départemental et régional des
grandes organisations comme les vôtres
et moi je suis très content que vous
puissiez être un partenaire qui est bien
nécessaire car il est nécessaire dans
l'école de créer un un environnement
bienveillant un environnement empathique
autour de l'élève on l'a bien entendu ce
matin effectivement à les préoccupations
des enseignants et de leurs
représentants et les parents d'élèves
eux aussi bien sûr ils ont besoin de
cette sécurité là au niveau de l'école
alors j'aurais deux questions à vous
poser parce que au niveau de la
négociation de la discussion sur la
refondation de l'école vos organisations
ont participé à leur place largement et
c'est tout à fait important qu'on puisse
réaliser cette coconstruction avec les
les organisations de parents d'élèves
par rapport à ce que le ministère
souhaitait et par rapport à surtout à ce
que aussi les parle parlementaire ont pu
apporter comme comme disons partie
ajoutée valeur ajoutée à ce que
proposait le gouvernement il y a
aujourd'hui la la préoccupation de
savoir comment vont se dérouler ensuite
les quelques mois qui viennent après ce
ce ce décret moi je souhaitais vous
demander mais certains d'entre vous
l'ont déjà dit est-ce que vous êtes prêt
à participer à laonstruction donc de
cette de ces circulaires maintenant que
la ministre va à pr pour préciser le
décret pour préciser les éléments de la
réforme et enfin une question qui vous
souvent tient beaucoup à cœur les
parents d'élèves c'est cette fameuse
liaison cm26e qui est bien intégrée
maintenant puisque dans le cycle 3 on
retrouve le CM1 le CM2 et et et la 6e
pour apporter aux élèves maintenant un
élément plus intéressant dans le passage
de l'enseignement primaire à
l'enseignement secondaire dans le
premier cycle euh dans le second cycle
pour pouvoir faire ce ce pas au-dessus
de ce fossé qui jusqu'à maintenant avait
été constaté et et dénoncé par par vos
organisations voilà donc simplement la
question que je voulais poser merci
merci Monsieur manier monsieur gros
Perin merci présidente et merci d'avoir
invité les
organisations de parents d'élèves parce
que je crois que c'est important qu'on
les entende même si à travers le trouble
qu'on a pu lire dans la presse ces
jours-ci vis-à-vis d'une association
on se rend compte que ce n'est pas
toujours une voix unique mais a des voix
discordantes et je crois que ça fait
partie de la démocratie d'entendre
d'autres chose même si on peut regretter
qu'un moment donné que certaines
associations puissent être de trop grand
de bon àoi en tout cas avec un trop
grand concert avec avec le gouvernement
parce que je suis pas sûr que ce soit le
rôle d'une association d'être un
transmetteur ou un ou un accélérateur de
de la réforme mais maintenant si ce sont
vos convictions je peux les comprendre
et je les entends deux deux choses et
c'est pour vous faire réagir bien sûr
pas simplement mes collègues sénateurs
mais les représentants d'organisation
syndicale si sur l'autonomie nous nous
sommes d'accord sur les 20 % je pense
que c'est une bonne chose parce que on
proposerait même d'aller un peu plus
loin si les enseignement
interdisciplinaire je pense que c'est
aussi intéressant et je crois que c'est
une réforme sur laquelle on peut on peut
s'appuyer on peut aussi acquesser parce
que même même j'ai même en entendant ou
en écoutant un ancien ministre
chvénement qui dit qu'il faut faire
l'interdisciplinaire mais
l'interdisciplinaire c'est bien
lorsqu'on connaît le disciplinaire je
crois que c'est bien aussi et il faut
s'en rappeler tout de même moi je
voudrais simplement avoir votre
sentiment sur sur plusieurs choses sur
les classes bilangues sur la suppression
du latin alors sur la dispar parce que
je pense que quelque part c'est un
sentiment moi ça témoigne surtout d'un
un état d'esprit parce que j'ai
l'impression et on a l'impression qu'il
y a une certaine forme de de suppression
de différenciation des parcours donc
c'est avoir vos sentiments par rapport à
ça et par là même la suppression ou la
baisse de toute forme de ce qu'on
appelait méritocratie ou d'élitisme donc
on s'interroge sur la question du
collège unique est-ce qu'il a
véritablement encore un sens à vos yeux
à ce jour est-ce que ça serait pas plus
intéressant de proposer des voies
beaucoup plus diversifié parce qu'on
pense on part du principe qu'en
supprimant bah le latin pour tous et en
mettant l'espagnol pour chacun c'est une
manière de faire en sorte que on
apportera beaucoup plus d'égalitarisme à
nos enfants on sait très bien que les
choses ne fonctionnent pas pour d'autres
raisons on l'a entendu tout à l'heure
pour différents types de raisons et les
gouvernements successifs je vous
l'accorde n'ont peut-être pas toujours
été à la hauteur dans la manière de
faire ou dans dans leur organisation
pour faire en sorte que les élèves
réussissent mieux mais je voudrais dire
quand même va falloir être bref monsieur
gr oui je voudrais dire quand même par
rapport par rapport votre sentiment par
rapport à à la deuxième langue la
deuxème langue parce que on sait qu'il y
a des problèmes de lecture en entré en
6e je crois qu'il y a un vrai problème
problème par rapport à cela il y a le
problème de l'oralité et de parler
français je v pas parler de la deuxième
langue du français parce que la première
serait l'anglais mais je crois qu'il y a
un véritable une inquiétude par rapport
à ça c'est connaître votre sentiment
également vis-à-vis de de la baisse du
service public parce que je suis
persuadé donc il y a l'appel qui est là
mais je suis persuadé que actuellement
on part dans un principe qui permettra à
l'établissement aux établissements
privés bon on peut comprendre on est
aussi pour le libre enseignement ou
différents types de de conception mais
on se rend compte que euh il est quand
même important qu'il a un collège d'État
qui soit un collège qui ne soit pas
toujours privé et on sait très bien que
dans le privé on l'a entendu que les
chefs d'établissement nous ont dit ou la
direction nationale nous a dit que de
toute manière pour ses orientations pour
ses langues pour ce bilinguisme pour et
cetera linguisme pardon et ces classes
euh en tout cas suppression du latin
qu'on veut remettre euh l'allemand qu'on
veut remettre également ils sont
capables de le faire d'un point de vue
financier avec des fonds propres donc on
va nécessairement poser un vrai problème
dem de conclure parce qu'on va pas tenir
les temps de la matinée alors deux
questions simplement euh je comprends
les disparition du latin on se focalise
sur des des des disciplines qui sont
exigeantes parce qu'on est dans un
certain état d'esprit de question est-ce
que cette réforme ne risquet-elle pas de
fragiliser le collège public c'est ma
première question parce que je pense que
on proposera d'autre chose dans le
l'enseignement privé est-ce que les
associations de parents d'élèves que
vous représentez ont-elles perçu ses
craintes de la part de membres et 3ème
question euh pensez-vous qu'il devrait y
avoir une modification de cette réforme
et s'il y en avait une pour certains
quelle serait-elle madame
bouchou euh madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues
euh sur ce qui vient d'être exposé par
les trois fédérations moi je voudrais
remercier vraiment pour ces trois
témoignages qui avec des des origines
très différentes des des points de vue
très différents euh dit quand même que
quelque chose que je pense nous devons
entendre que les choses telles qu'elles
ont été formulées dans ce décret non
obstant des critique nonobstant des
réserves moi j'ai entendu alors
peut-être ai-je mal entendu de trois
personnes avec des mots différents que
globalement la démarche allait dans le
bon sens donc je voudrais juste vérifier
que je n'ai pas mal compris et
deuxièmement oser une hypothèse c'est
que peut-être il y a une différence dans
cette table ronde et la précédente c'est
la question de l'entre soi c'est-à-dire
que dans la table ronde précédente nous
ét dans l'entre soi et d'ailleurs aussi
aussi dans l'entre soi sur les bancs
puisque nos provenances font que
beaucoup sont originaires du monde
enseignant et donc je je voulais poser
cette question aux parents s'ils ne
pensent pas que la diversité de leur de
leur point de vue qui est très grande et
qui qui concorde dans le même sens ne
vient pas du fait que le travail en
équipe qui va être à la base de cette de
ces nouveaux textes est en fait ce qui
est la lae la vraie vie réelle et
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait on part de la
réalité telle qu'elle est on a des êtres
humains en face et on essaie d' aller
dans le bon sens pour répondre à la
question comment faisons-nous pour que
tous nos gamins pour que tous les élèves
réussissent à l'école et j'avais une
deuxième question à poser qui me qui me
tient très à cœur concernant la la place
des parents dans l'institution scolaire
et bien chiche du coup concrètement
qu'est-ce qu'on peut améliorer
réellement dans les conseils
d'administration pour faire en sorte que
ces instances très importantes
auxquelles nous sommes très attachés ne
soi pas que des chambres
d'enregistrement mais des lieux de
dialogue où on peut en ensemble mettre
sur le terrain ce que vous avez dit
aller dans le bon sens voilà comment
est-ce qu'on peut faire plutôt que
d'être toujours à détricoter quand je
pense qu'il y a des pays pas loin d'ici
où deux parties opposés arrivent à
gouverner ensemble et ici moi je me suis
aperçu au bout d'une heure que tous des
profs tous veulent le bonheur des élèves
mais tous lisent un texte différent dans
le même décret moi je vous avoue que ça
m'a énormément perturbé la première
table ronde que toutes ces personnes
j'ai compté on était à bac + 128 comment
avec bac + 128 on n'arrivait pas tous à
lire le même texte ce qui me rassure
c'est que les parents eux ont à peu près
lu la même chose je vous en remercie
merci Madame bouchou alors je redonne la
parole à Madame Marti pour répondre à
l'ensemble des des questions qui ont été
posées j'u oui alors sur la première
question à savoir est-ce que la réforme
se fait au détriment des apprentissages
fondamentaux nous la réflexion qu'on a
mené avec les parents on leur a demandé
quand on quand il était question de
réfléchir sur le
collège qu'est-ce qu'ils attendaient au
collège et en fin de compte la première
des des réponses les parents d'élèves
s'étent euh s'était prononcé
favorablement à la diminution des heures
fondamental des disciplines il préfèrent
faire mieux que plus mais qu'il y ait de
l'accompagnement c'est-à-dire que les
enseignants accompagne essae de
personnaliser leur enseignement essae
d'aider au mieux qu'on puisse dégager
des heures pour aider les élèves à
progresser ça c'était une volonté des
parents je pense pas qu'en faisant plus
d'heur à un moment donné on arrive à
mieux faire c'est un petit peu la
réflexion euh que je voulais vous vous
donner alors sur la question comment on
peut résorber les les lacunes des élèves
qui arrivent au collège effectivement il
y a des élèves qui arrivent avec des
très très grandes lacunes on sait très
bien qu'ils ne vont pas combler ces
lacunes qu'au contraire leur niveau
scolaire va s'abaisser et ça c'est une
vraie difficulté donc c'est pour ça que
les parents d'élèves dans cette réforme
du collège ce qu'ils veulent et ce
qu'ils ne perçoivent pas je dirais c'est
pour ça que j'ai dit que la PEP n'était
pas convaincu c'est comment cette
réforme pas prendre en compte la grande
diversité des élèves et comment elle va
faire pour aider tous les élèves à
progresser et les amener plus loin c'est
là où les parents ne perçoivent pas
comment euh tous ces tous ces faits vont
pouvoir amener et avoir une une une
finalité qui est de mieux faire réussir
les élèves à sortie du du collège
euh alors sur les enseignements euh
transdisciplinaires et sur leur
pertinence je dirais que oui sur les
itinéraires de découverte euh c'est vrai
que dans certains collèges ils ont un
peu perdu leur sens et que on voit plus
très bien l'intérêt de ces dispositifs
donc attention par contre au niveau du
lycée les les travaux lesétit pe on on
par contre beaucoup d'intérêt et les
élèves y apprennent beaucoup de choses
donc il y a à mon avis la fragilité de
la mise en œuvre des des epis et là
c'est-à-dire comment je vais faire
comment on va pouvoir gérer ces
enseignements transdisciplinaires au
sein des établissements scolaires
comment l'éducation nationale va réussir
à accompagner les équipes d'enseignants
à à réaliser cela je pense
qu'effectivement là on pointe le
problème de la gouvernance c'est-à-dire
comment je fais une réforme et comment
je la mets en œuvre et comment j'aide
les enseignants les équipes à rendre
cette réforme pratique leur donner un
sens et faire en sorte que pour les
élèves au sein des établissement
scolaire c'est cela est un
intérêt alors concernant la disparition
des options professionnelles je dirais
que bah écoutez en fonction des
établissements en fonction de de
l'implication des enseignants ça pouvait
être extrêmement bien comme ça pouvait
être extrêmement pauvre et qu'on y
mettait dans certains cas des élèves en
ne sachant pas trop ce qui ce qu'ils
avaient envie de faire en difficulté et
on essayit bonormalon d'essayer de leur
donner un sens à à ces ces découvertes
professionnelles donc sur le Piot map
c'est vrai que pour nous parents on a un
petit peu de mal à voir comment ça va
s'organiser et là c'est encore une fois
un problème de gouvernance et comment on
va pouvoir mettre en pratique quelque
chose qui qui effectivement a du sens
c'est-à-dire que faire en sorte que les
élèves puissent construire un parcours
essayer de réfléchir à ce qu'ils vont
pouvoir faire dans le
futur alors concernant les j'essaie de
prendre il faut que je me dépêche c'est
ça je pas vous stressez rassurez-vous je
pensais que vousz une pause et vous
aviez terminé donc juste deux trois
questions en plus euh sur les la
question des grandes fédérations et
l'opposition avec les associations
isolées je crois que il faut que je
pense que nous nous avons la même idée
et nous faisons le même constat il faut
nous réformer il est temps aussi nous
fédération de parents d'élèves euh
peut-être de répondre mieux aux attentes
des parents et de de nous euh
de proposer en tout cas une autre forme
de d'animation et de de répondre à ses
besoins afin que les grandes fédérations
de parents d'élèves puissent toujours
avoir leur place c'est vrai qu'on voit
que sur des sujets comme comme les
rythmes scolaires ou même le collège et
cetera on est capable en interne d'avoir
des discussions d'avoir des va viens
enfin nous on a mené une grande enquête
et là je je peux pas vous donner les
résultats aujourd'hui parce qu'on a un
bug informatique mais je pourrais le je
le vous le transmettre il y a cette
réflexion de va sans cesse auprès de nos
parents pour permettre d'avoir une
discussion un petit peu sur comment ils
perçoivent les répores les questions
c'estàdire ce qu'on ne comprend pas et
mener un petit un petit peu un débat au
sein de la communauté éducative et ça me
paraît très important alors oui on
participerea on participe toujours à la
construction au dialogue avec le
ministère donc on continuera sur les
circulaires quant à la liaison cm26e
réellement moi je n'ai pas perçu en tant
que parents d'élèves que c'était cette
liaison alors sur le papier il existe
quelque chose mais les parents n'y sont
pas associés donc la CM2 la liaison cm
de 6e c'est pour les enseignants mais
pas pour les parents voilà pour ces
auditions sur le thème de la réforme du
collège vous avez pu suivre les audition
par la commission de la culture du Sénat
des représentants des syndicats des
enseignants ainsi que les représentants
des associations de parents d'élèves
parmi les thèmes abordés la mobilisation
des enseignants de la semaine dernière
mais aussi et surtout la réforme le
contenu de la réforme la réforme des
programmes avec notamment la suppression
annoncée des classes bilangues l'avenir
de l'enseignement des langues anciennes
comme le latin et le grec ou encore la
refonte du programme d'histoire la
commission de la culture souhaitait
auditionner nadjad Valo Belkassem la
semaine dernière une audition qui a été
reportée sinédié alors que le décret
d'application de la réforme était publié
au Journal officiel au même moment vous
pouvez t voir et revoir cette audition
et toutes les autres sur notre site
publicsena.fr très bonne suite des
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires